there have to be reasons that you get up
in the morning and you want to live like
why do you want to live what what's the
point what what inspires you what what
do you love about the future try to
learn a little bit about a lot of things
cuz you might not know what you're
really interested how would you know
what you're really interested in it's
better to be optimistic and wrong
occasionally than pessimistic and right
you hear about the startups that succeed
but most companies are a massive amount
of of of work qued by failure I don't
care about optimism or pessimism that
we're going to get it done don't satisfy
your customers figure out how to
absolutely Delight them everything I've
ever done has started small my view is I
don't even like praise work life balance
I think it's misleading I like the
phrase work life Harmony never chase the
hot thing whatever it is that's like
trying to catch the wave and you'll
never catch it you need to position
yourself and wait for the wave our
biggest regrets turn out to be acts of
omission it's paths not taken and they
haunt us we wonder what would have
happened I loved that person and I never
told him and then they married somebody
else and I have seen all kinds of very
very smart people self-destruct one way
or another in business or particularly
in in in the stock market and they they
stray outside of their circle of
competence if you can in life work at
what you love with people you love you
know it comes back at you love is
something you can't get rid of if you
give it to other people you get it back
if you try to hold on to it disappears I
mean it's unlike anything anything else
in the world you are going to move in
the direction of the people you
associate with you don't really need
brains what do you need you need the
right orientation all the early
businesses that we on the other have
disappeared they didn't disappear they
failed they failed the thing that
determines your destiny is not a
competitor it's how you execute the
biggest risk you can take is not taking
any risk nothing is impossible you just
have to kind of keep running through the
walls I just think part of learning is
failing for my particular makeup I mean
it really is true that I didn't believe
in weekends I didn't believe in
vacations I mean you know I knew
everybody's license plate so I can tell
you over the last month when they're car
come and gone from the the parking lot
yes we had to fight for acceptance I
couldn't rent cars so I had to take cabs
around cuz I was too young and if you
want to learn physics Fineman wrote the
book uh just read the damn book it's all
there hey it's EV car Michael and I
watch these videos every day because I
need them for motivation being around
successful entrepreneurs every morning
helps me believe that I can do great
things to it's like your morning coffee
but for your goals kickstarting your day
with a blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
hashtag believe in the comments below so
I can celebrate with
you so today let's get some incredible
motivation from billionaires enjoy if
you don't succeed with your first
startup it shouldn't be sort of a
catastrophic career ending thing it
should be you know well good I think
should like should be like well you know
you gave it a good shot you know and and
and now try again exactly and it's so
one thing I was going to mention is like
obviously creating a company is sort of
a high-risk High reward uh situation um
but and I don't know quite what the how
it works in in the UK I think it's
probably better than than um Continental
Europe um but the the stock options are
very difficult in most parts of Europe
I'm not sure how do the UK but but if
somebody's basically going to risk their
their sort of life savings and with and
the vast majority of startups fail so I
mean you hear about the startups that
succeed but most companies are most
startups consist of you know a massive
amount of of of work um followed by
failure that's actually most most
companies and so it's a highrisk higher
reward and and and so the higher reward
part does need to be there for it to
make sense what would you say say to
young people that want to change the
world that have big Ideas what advice
could you give I would say you know go
do it um you just just go out there and
and and do it um the I mean the biggest
thing I think people uh fail to do is
that they they they're they're too
afraid to try things you know that they
shouldn't be afraid of of of failing and
and they should just go go and do it did
you fail at anything that you tried I've
I've lost I mean I've not lost a war but
I've lost battle certainly M mean the
first three um flights of of the Falcon
one rocket uh they crashed wow that must
have been a big bummer yeah it was a big
bummer did you cry no never trust a
cynic the reason is that um cynics
excuse their own bad behavior by saying
everyone does
it because they're
cynical so I always be it's a red flag
if someone's a cynic a true cynic yeah
there's a degree a projection there
that's always fun to watch from the
outside and enjoy the
hypocrisy if but but I this is an
important point that I think people who
are listening should bear in mind if if
somebody is cynical meaning that they
see bad behavior in everyone um it's
easy for them to excuse their own bad
behavior by saying that well everyone
does
it that's not
true I most people are kind of medium
good what motivates you what's the Big
Driver well I mean generally I'm what
I'm trying to do is uh take the set of
actions that maximize the probability
that the future will be good uh for
civilization that we will expand the
scale of scope scope and scale of
Consciousness uh so that we're better
able to understand the nature of the
universe so I call my i' say I have like
a philosophy of curiosity um that's
maybe best articulated by Douglas Adams
in the hitra GU of the Galaxy okay um so
we're you know that's really it you
famously has like the a big computer
comes up with the answer 42 but the
really hard part is what question to ask
um so I think it's like we want
to try to understand more about the
nature of the
universe understand like what does it
all mean where where do we come from
where are we going what does this all
end up as what's real are there aliens I
mean well they seem to be confirming
some stuff quite recently I mean I I
have yet to see act any actual evidence
of of aliens so and I'm really deep in
space yeah so
um yeah uh I I mean if if if there is
some actual evidence of aliens or an
actual UFO I'll be there in a second you
know I mean obviously you know it's like
are we talking about buddies here like
is it a UFO is there technology I mean
that would
be very very interesting um and
hopefully they're friendly uh they manag
to get all the way here from another
star system I mean their technology is
going to be far in acccess I mean we're
will be primitive compared to them you
know so um but I also think like if if
there aren't aliens or that that's
actually have to even a a bigger concern
because um if there actually aren't
aliens in our galaxy or anywhere near us
then
effectively uh this Consciousness this
Consciousness on planet Earth is um the
light of Consciousness is like it's a a
tiny candle in a vast
Darkness um and a fragile candle and we
should just do everything we can to make
sure it does not go out also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight our
favorite lessons from the video that
will inspire you to remember what you
learned today and actually apply them
the worksheet will also give you space
to write down what your key takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet designed specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there how do you balance
your life I mean with this stress with
so many different you know you're on so
many different company parallel how do
you balance
it well I mean I I should point out that
I a 20-hour work day is relatively
unusual and and rather painful um but
but I I do sleep 6 hours a night so um
and if I sleep less than 6 hours a night
I find that I am I might be awake longer
but I get less done so
um but I I I do have work a ridiculous
amount I think relative to um most
people and and that it's pretty much 7
days a week and mostly from when I wake
up to when I go to sleep um I'm not
suggesting this is good
for everyone and I think frankly I would
like to work a bit less than that
so um I think you if I look at say Tesla
Tesla went through some very difficult
times where it was on the Ragged edge of
survival and and uh really if I if I
didn't get everything I got I think the
company could have easily gone bankrupt
it was really on the verge of bankruptcy
for quite a while um I don't mean to
suggest complacency at this point but uh
you know it does require much less work
um to operate Tesla Now versus say in
the 2017 to 2019 time frame
um and it's it's not at Mortal risk of
of surviv it's achieved economies of
scale that make it you know not uh on
the Ragged edge of survival
um and then then SpaceX also has a
strong team and is able to make a lot of
progress um even if I spend less time
there um it it does help if I spend time
there but uh you know it keeps making
progress even if I don't um Twitter is
is still somewhat of a startup in
reverse and so there's a lot of work
required here to get Twitter to a sort
of a stable position
um and uh like I said to really build
the engine of engineering of software
engineering at at Twitter and have it
um you know really have like said a
great product road map and and the
people in place to implement that
product road map and so it is not my
intention to work um like
crazy you know I mean I think I still I
I think I be comfortable with a 80h hour
work week would be fine all
right U as that is what I would aspire
to when you think about education and
self-education what do you recommend I'd
encourage people to read a lot of
books just read like basically try to
ingest as much information as you
can uh and try to also just develop a
good general knowledge um so so you at
least have like a rough lay of the land
of the the knowledge
landscape um like try to learn a little
bit about a lot of things um CU you
might not know what you're really
interested how would you know what
you're really interested in if you at
least aren't like doing it peripheral
exp exploration of broadly of of the
knowledge
landscape
um and and you talk to people from
different walks of life and different uh
Industries and professions and skills
and OCC occupations like just try learn
as much as possible I would encourage
people to read broadly um in many
different subject areas and then try to
find something where there's an overlap
of your talents and and what you're
interested in so people may may be good
at something but or they may have SK
skill at a particular thing but they
don't like doing it MH um so you want to
try to find thing where you have you're
that's a good a good uh combination of
of your of the things that you're
inherently good at but you also like
doing why do we need to build a city on
Mars with a million people on it in your
lifetime which I I think is kind of what
you've said you'd love to
do yeah I think it's important to have a
future that is inspiring and appealing I
mean I just think that there like there
have to be reasons that you get up in
the morning and you want to live like
why do you want to live what what's the
point what what inspires you what what
do you love about the future and if if
we're not out there if the future is not
include being out there Among the Stars
um and being a multiplet species I find
that it's incredibly depressing if
that's not the future that we're going
to have I think the the value of beauty
and inspiration is very much underrated
no question but I want to be clear I
like I'm not trying to be anyone's
savior uh that is not
the I'm just trying to think about the
future and not be sad how do you deal
with a people who say no you are
shooting too far ahead you are trying to
do something that's impossible don't
bother doing it or uh or are resistant
to change how do you manage those that
resistance the naysayers out there and
continue
on well I would go back to physics in
that um the only things that are truly
impossible are breaking the laws of
physics um so as long as you're not
breaking laws of physics um it's
possible um and it doesn't matter what
anyone's opinion is um you know physics
is the law and everything else is a
recommendation I've seen plenty of
people break the law but I've never seen
anyone break physics anything within the
laws of physics is
possible yeah I mean and you can
certainly challenge the laws of physics
but uh they've been challenged quite
well and uh have found to be resilient
where do you go to both
personally um intellectually as an
engineer as a team like for source of
strength needed to sort of persevere
through this and to act keep going with
the project take it to completion a SCE
of strength h i I just really not how I
think about things um I mean for me it's
simply this this is something that is
important to get done um and we we
should just keep doing it um or die
trying and I I don't need a source of
strength so quitting is not even like um
it's not it's not in my nature okay and
I I don't care about optimism or
pessimism that we're going to get it
done I me I'm generally of the view
philosophically philosophically that
it's better to be optimistic and wrong
occasionally than pessimistic and right
um you know uh you I think you want to
look on the bright bright side of things
and um and I'm a little worried that
um uh young people today maybe sometimes
are a little pessimistic about the
future but like I I'd like to just
assure people that so long as we are not
complacent we will solve the climate we
solve the climate crisis and we will
solve these issues um we obviously need
to take them seriously and work hard to
solve them they will be solved um and
that people should be optimistic about
the future and and work to make that
optimistic future real you know they say
the the best way to predict the future
is to create it um and so if you take
the actions necessary for there to be a
good future then we will have a good
future um and um so I'd encourage people
to be optimistic take the actions that
will create a good future and we will
have one I know you're a huge reader um
but from a um a lifelong learning
perspective constantly trying to add to
your toolkit so that you're you know a
better leader a better CEO are there
recommendations that you have for the
audience about those kinds of things
that you do to keep yourself mentally
sharp well I read a lot less these days
and I used to when I was a kid I was
read all the time
um I mean mostly subscribe to Scientific
periodicals like um you know like the
The Daily News I find to be a lot of
noise um and just very negative uh so I
generally try to not read The Daily News
that much um because generally
newspapers try to seem to be trying to
answer the question what is the worst
thing that happened on Earth
today Earth's big okay there's a lot of
people something terrible happened every
single day guaranteed big big plan also
something great happened but there don't
answer that question um so that's the
Daily News just tends to make one
measurable that like the um science
science and tech technology periodicals
are quite interesting um and usually you
know if there's something some new
discovery it'll be in there
um so and you I find Twitter
enlightening at times you know uh you
learn learn a it there um and and
talking to smart people all the time uh
is very helpful um um because that can
be a distillation of of of interesting
things that are going on um and you know
certainly like try to ask people like
for the car like what are we doing wrong
you know what can we fix what can we
make better and they usually just want
to tell me oh it's great you I love it
like sure I understand but what's wrong
with it and like what can we make better
you know this is this theory of like how
do we be less wrong starting a company
is is a very tough thing um there's a
friend of mine bully who's who's is you
know starting a company is like um
staring into the abyss and and eating
glass um so uh you should certainly
expect that it is going to be very hard
um it's going to be harder than getting
a job somewhere uh by by a pretty good
margin um and um the odds of you losing
the money that you've invested or your
friends have invested is is pretty high
I mean that's just those are just basic
facts um
so uh if if you don't mind things being
really hard and and and high risk then
uh starting a company is is a good idea
otherwise it's it's probably unwise uh
and we'll certainly stress you
out um so I think you have to be pretty
pretty driven to make it happen um
otherwise you will just make yourself
miserable
um and then and then in in creating
company as I said a moment ago it's just
uh you just want to really say how do
you make the best product of service
possible um you know companies that
don't make good products or service
Services just shouldn't exist what are
your thoughts on the Innovations in
education today thank you uh just the
thoughts on education um well
um I I think there's maybe um there's
definitely some good schools out there
um but I think the
some of the the mistakes at least in my
opinion that I see being made in
education is
um that um people the teachers do not
explain why kids are being taught a
subject um you know just sort of get
dumped into math and like well why are
you learning math what's the point of
this this seems like some you know for
some people like maybe it's like I don't
know why I'm being asked to do these
strange problems uh but you know the why
of things is extremely important um
because you know our brain has evolved
to not to discard information that it
thinks is has no relevance so then if on
the one hand you uh you're being asked
to memorize or learn uh say formulas um
but you don't not know why this is the
case then you have this cognitive
dissonance of it seems irrelevant but
I'm being told to remember it so I'll be
punished
so so I better remember it but so the
why of things is very important and then
uh being able to and and then Pi picking
kind of a a problem and then uh using
various Educational Tools to solve that
problem um like using math or physics or
economics to to solve that problem is
far more engaging um than teaching the
tools um you know it's difference
between if you say well we're going to
take apart this uh this engine um and
and see how it works and put it back
together again um and then in order to
take the engine apart we need you know
wrenches and screwdrivers and a winch um
and Allen keys and and whatnot um and
and and so and then in the course of
solving the problem of taking the engine
apart and putting it back together you
learn about branches and screwdrivers
and all the tools that you need um and
then now you understand the relevance ah
this is why
wrenches are important I you know
whereas if you had a a class on
wrenches be like why does this thises
not seem that great you know um so tying
it to solving a problem is I think very
powerful for um establishing relevance
and getting um kids excited about what
they're working on um and then and uh
and having the knowledge stick SpaceX
you have said
you've started with the specific
intention of getting to
Mars uh yeah it well the origin of
SpaceX uh was was actually not or it my
interest in Spa my inial thought in
space was that uh it wasn't possible to
create a company um and I mistakenly
thought that uh the reason that we had
not send people to MOS was because we'd
lost the will to explore or something
like May that and I thought well maybe
that needs to be reignited and so came
with this idea to do a basically a
philanthropic mission to M with with a
100% probability of losing all the money
um in order to reignite interest in that
goal um but after after a while I
realized that's that was actually that
was a mistake I mean particularly United
States is is a nation of explorers you
know came here from other parts of the
world um I think more than any other
country is just of the human Spirit of
exploration there there's no lack of
will the but people need to believe that
there's a way uh that that in a way
that's feasible and and that it's not
going to bankrupt the country and their
living standard will be won't be
materially affected you know if and then
I think they're super super keen on on
that that goal I think like sci-fi uh
movies video games or you know and
really I think people spend a lot more
time on on video games and movies these
days uh you know can be pretty inspiring
and Thor provoking about what's the
future that we want uh what are some
like impossible sounding technologies
that may maybe could work somehow um
like there's conceivably a way to do
warp drive but it's like it's
such esoteric super out on the edge
physics because technically you cannot
go faster than the speed of light uh but
but space can travel faster than the
speed of light
that's what's meant by Wolf Drive but
the amount of energy you need to wol
space
is unbelievably gigantic so
um you know you'd have to like be
converting matter to energy at a rate
that is we cannot conceive really um you
know it can't be like something well if
we just con convert one Jupiter per
second to energy then problem solved uh
like there a lot and there's not many
Jupiters
um you know so uh and there might be a
bit of radiation around that so like
there are things like like technically
the the universe did expand faster than
the speed of light that's that's uh
that's why we can see uh light from all
these super distant stars um
like yeah so it's it's kind of pretty
wild that space expanded faster than
speed of light um so I'm sure like
figure out some strange breakthroughs um
and you know come to griffs better with
like this uh this do matter especially
which seems like something's fishy going
on there
um and uh it has bad
branding
yeah yeah
exactly the universe is mostly dark
energy and dark matter according to
current current physics but you know
this kind of plug in the you plug them
in the equations and they sort of work
and I'm like this this not a good
explanation nobody can find the doc
matter um but I sort of figure like hey
if this was a video game and somebody
had a bug in their like orbital Dynamics
uh physics simulator then I like oh no
we got to figure out some way for these
minions in here to uh believe that
they're in reality so insert dog matter
I'd actually advocate for I think it's
fine if if if countries get together to
form teams but I think it's actually
probably better if there are at least
you know at least two or three uh
country coalitions going going to Mars
um in a friendly way um and and
competing to see who can make the most
progress um if you look at like say the
Olympics it would be pretty boring if
everyone just linked arms and crossed
the finishing line at the same
time um friendly um but it would you
know not be more like the opening
ceremonies I guess yeah yeah EX exactly
um so I think friendly competition is a
good thing you have to um imagine an
outcome in order to head in that
direction um and science fiction
explores a lot of different ideas so um
it can be you know helpful as a source
of inspiration um and and you know like
books TV shows movies I me they're all
uh I think sources of inspiration um I
mean most of the movies TV shows that
space are totally wrong uh but uh but
they still have interesting ideas like
the Star Trek Communicator um was uh an
inspiration for the cell phone yeah with
the flip right right yeah exactly um I'm
in fact the weird thing is like the like
the phones we have in our pocket fastly
exceed what was on Star Trek first of
all I think that's pry exciting and
inspiring and there need to be things
that are exciting and inspiring and uh
make you look forward to waking up in
the morning like it's like Yay the
future is exciting this is
underappreciated you know like
tunnels sorry like
all um and
um you know but there's got to be things
that make you excited about life um but
you it can't just be problem solving you
know one one sort of miserable problem
after another it's got to be like I'm
fired up about the future here's why you
know and and space is one of those
things that that does that for people
all around the world um you know when um
when Apollo 11 you know when when they
landed on the Moon I mean it was that
was something for all of humanity really
was you know people would you know if
there's like one TV for 50 miles around
people would walk you know they'd walk
50 miles just to go find that one TV to
to watch it happen um so you know people
think what about what what about the
poor nations of the world like you know
what Inspire inspires them too um and um
you know we need things like that an
important thing in in uh Innovation or
trying to create new things is is is to
try really hard to to do that um which
may sound incredibly obvious but uh
that's what I find is is most often what
people don't do they actually didn't
didn't try super hard to come up with
something new um and and it is helpful
to have cross pollination of Industries
um I mean it's been quite difficult to
run SpaceX and Tesla but there has
been good ideas you know if since I got
both in my mind space this this good
ideas going back and forth the um for
example on the car with respect to the
car the model S is the only all aluminum
body and Chassy car made in North
America and very few cars are are all
aluminum in the airspace industry it's
that that's the default um so it seemed
like like obviously the right move in
order to minimize the the non battery
pack mass of the car so in order to
offset you know fairly heavy battery
pack we had to make the rest of the car
light but but still achieve uh a
five-star safety rating um I don't think
it would have been possible to do that
if we had used steel which is the
traditional method um and and what's
helped SpaceX has been that the the car
industry is really good at making
complicated objects at a low cost I mean
it's actually quite incredible that like
one can
buy a decent car for $20,000 I mean all
the stuff that's in that car is I mean
it's nutty how much stuff is in a car
um so uh that at SpaceX uh I hired a
bunch of people from the Auto industry
to uh run manufacturing which is worked
out reasonably well what's the actual
biggest failure that you that you've
gone through to get to where you are I
mean we blew up three rockets on the
beginning
so that
was that that was bad uh we actually I
only had enough money originally I only
I basically took all all the money I
made from PayPal put it into SpaceX to
creating SpaceX Tesla and and solver
City and uh initially figured i' I just
I'd keep half of it and then I spend the
other half on these crazy Adventures
that would probably fail um and then
unfortunately they needed all the money
so so I had to give them all the money
and then I didn't have a house or add to
borrow money for rent that was that was
pretty difficult that was back in 2008
um and then we managed to scrape enough
spare parts together to do a fourth
launch at SpaceX um and that worked and
if it had not worked SpaceX would have
died probably would have lacked The
credibility to raise the remaining money
for Tesla and we wouldn't be here today
or maybe
like not this ending I think uh you so
so when you when you create a company I
mean if you think what is a company
really a company is a group of people
gathered together to create a product or
service and that that's really what the
company is and so you have to really
believe in what you're creating and and
that it's and and and know in your heart
and mind that this is something that
matters that and and and that uh the
world ought to have
um and I think it's important to
investors to to show that that you're
you're all in and I think for example
with with
Tesla um the the fact that I invested
all the money I had literally I had to
borrow money from friends to to pay the
rent in in 2008 um
uh the fact so the fact that I was all
in I think was hugely made a huge
difference to to the
investors um to convince them to invest
in in in Tesla uh at the same time that
that say GM and Cho were were going
bankrupt um and uh yeah I think you have
to show that you you're really care like
it's like you you um that you've got
skin in the game and that
you've given it everything that you've
got and then the other people at the
company uh will call the suit as as well
investors I I think that's really
important why do you think Tesla
succeeded whereas other car companies
failed in their methods of electric of
electric cars like why do you think
Tesla is the leader in this
idea well um I mean there haven't been
that many car company startups uh I
there was sort of Fisker uh and Coda um
and and then a few smaller ones um and
and then the rest has sort of
been some some fairly small scale
efforts by the big
companies
um
uh I I I
think if if we say what was the
difference between say Fisker and Tesla
that's maybe the bit most direct
comparison uh Tesla is a hardcore
engineering company and visker is kind
of a was based on kind of on styling you
know it's like styling is good important
but it's that's not the reason we don't
have electric cars so it's not you know
bit for styling we we would have
electric cars that's not the reason um
so in the case of Visa they made a car
that uh a lot of people think looked
really good but didn't work properly so
then people don't want to buy the car um
that's like a pretty reasonable thing I
think
um and yeah
um yeah I me if you think like like what
what what's the point of a company
existing the the point is that it's it's
a group of people that have gathered
together to create a product if the
product is good the company should exist
and if it is not good the company should
not exist
um that seems like fundamental to the
nature of companies so the I mean
clearly then one should focus on making
the absolute best product you
can otherwise you reduce the probability
of success but a lot of companies focus
on things that aren't really to do with
the product um as though a company has
any basis for existing apart from doing
useful things
that's kind of strange so after that
third
trip I i' learned a lot more about
rockets at that point um and I I held a
series of meetings um just just sort of
brainstorming sessions with people from
the the space industry to try to
understand if there was if I was missing
something fundamental about um the
ability to improve rocketry um and this
is where I think it's helpful to use the
approach yeah the the the anal approach
in physics which is to try to boil
things down to First principles and and
reason from there as opposed to
reasoning by
analogy um
so and and the way this applied to to
ratry was to say okay
well um what are the what are the
materials that that go into a rocket um
how you know how much does each material
constituent uh weigh um what's the cost
of that raw material
and and that and that's going to set
some floor um as as to the cost of the
rocket and and that actually turns out
to be a relatively small number um
certainly
um well under 5% of the cost of a rocket
and in some cases closer to 1 or
2% um and so I call it sort of maybe the
the magic wand number so if you if you
had a pile of of of of of the raw
material piles of raw materials on the
floor and you could just wave magic wand
and rearrange them um then then that
would be the the the best case scenario
for for a rocket and so I was able to
see okay well there's clearly a great
deal of room for improvement even if you
consider Rockets to be
Expendable um and and so so I think
that's that's sort of that's what I mean
by sort of thinking about things from a
first principal standpoint if if on the
other hand I sort of analyze it by
analogy and said okay well analogy would
be well what are all other rocket
companies what what do their Rockets
cost what historically have have other
Rockets cost and that would be sort of
an analogy thing but it really doesn't
illustrate what the true potential is um
and and so I I think sort of first
principle first principles approach is
is is a good way to um to understand
what new things are possible so this
this is a good a good framework here's
another question um from a Tesla
owner why is there no coat hook in the
back
yeah he says he or she says you can
design a rocket but you forgot the coat
hooks well I didn't actually forget it I
just I intentionally didn't like it so I
didn't put it there um like the
Aesthetics of it really bothered me but
um I know you know obviously some people
disagree with that decision um but I
think I think we might have
um a retroactive fix for that if
somebody has the pan IC roof uh which is
to to basically have a hook on the the
bow section in the middle of the roof um
and then the then the your code could
hang down in the second row passenger
foot well which is actually slightly
better than having a coat hook uh that's
stuck on the side of the car
um so I think we'll probably do that um
yeah the first three flights of the
Falcon one failed or or rather the they
certainly didn't get to orbit uh the
second and third flights arguably got to
space but but they did not reach full
orbital velocity um and then fortunately
the fourth flight worked um and if it
hadn't uh SpaceX wouldn't be around cuz
I'd basically run out of money so that
would that was a bit of a nailbiter
um and um thank goodness uh so and in
fact uh this all happened in in 2008
so um yeah there was really no ability
to to raise outside money in a
meaningful way in 2008 was of the
financial crisis um so you can imagine
trying to go to raise money saying well
yes we just had four failures and the
world is in financial ruin but would you
like to give us some money um that would
be a definite no um so fortunately that
that that succeeded um and um and we're
able to go from One to begin designing
the Falcon line which is an order of
magnitude larger vehicle in fact um has
more than 20 times the payload so it's
got a payload to orbit of of over over
10 tons um and uh and and and that
actually has gone a lot um a lot better
uh because we had the the experience of
Falcon 1 to go by um and and part of the
reason we started with Falcon one was
because I I I I I thought we would make
a lot of mistakes and if if we're going
to make a lot of mistakes then it's it's
best to make those mistakes at a small
scale rather than at a large scale um
and and that seems to have worked that
um because going to Falcon 9 we've had
four flights of Falcon 9 and they've all
um been all four of them have been
successful um so I think that that
principle seems to have worked
reasonably well you know touch word and
all that life five is coming up soon how
do you balance your capacity for risk
your risk tolerance against your desire
to continue to innovate I think that one
I I mean I was certainly facing the loss
of all assets I mean technically I would
have been negative because I would have
been owing people money um but uh but I
I I figured I could always make enough
to you know uh or just borrow enough to
pay the rent and and you know buy food
and that kind of thing so I didn't think
we would starve or or lack for shelter
um although it would be would have been
sad to not to have lost all the assets
gained from um prior companies
uh um but really the toughest decision
was was not whether to invest the money
into Tesla it was really
um that had Tesla and SpaceX and the the
tough decision was
if if I if I split the money between the
two companies then it's possible that
both may still have died um and so I I I
had to decide would I dedicate funds to
just one company or and let the other
one die for sure or split the funds
between the two companies and that's
that that was a really that was the
really difficult decision how much time
do you have to go down into the engine
room roll up your sleeves get your hands
dirty and fix stuff as an engineer and
how much time do you spend on the bridge
steering and looking at the at the
distant
Horizon well not a lot on that last
Point uh I mean it's uh I mean there
there's a constant flurry of executional
challenges um and so I try to triage my
time according to what would be best for
the companies uh and and still you know
have some time see my kids you know
because I want most of them growing up
so it you know it can vary from big
issues to things that seem small but
actually could have a really big impact
um so I mean it's it's all the way from
design Aesthetics to uh the details of
of say the vehicle functionality or in
the case of the rocket uh you know the
avionics propulsion system and uh
airframe I mean the rocket is kind of a
has has more more of a concentrated
pucker Factor um because you got it's
you got these launches and
and um at least for the car you can do a
recoil or like do a software update
that's not going to happen with the
rocket
so it's like passing grade is
100% uh which is induces anxiety you
know and I think in the future uh people
look back and say um wow I can't believe
we had to drive these cars ourselves you
know it like soft driving cars will just
be just a normal like self-driving
elevators you know uh elevators used to
have elevator operators and there's
someone there with like you know big big
relay switch uh operating the elevator
and then every now and then they get
tired or you know some make a mistake
and Shear somebody in half so um so now
we uh you know we made elevators
automatic and you just go and you press
press the button and you can be in a 100
story skyscraper and don't really worry
about it just go in and press a button
and uh the elevator takes you where you
want to go um but it used to be that all
elevators were operated man manually
it'll be the same thing like for cars
all all cars will be automatic um and
then um and and electric obviously um so
there will still be some gasoline cars
and some manual cars just like there are
still some horses my view is I don't
even like the phrase work life balance I
think it's misleading I like the phrase
work life Harmony because I know that if
I am energized at work happy at work
feeling like I'm adding value um part of
a team whatever energizes
you that makes me better at home it
makes me a better husband a better
father and likewise if I'm happy at home
it makes me a better employee a better
boss all the things it's not about it's
not primarily about there may be crunch
periods where it's about the number of
hours in the week but that that's not
the mo that's not the real thing usually
it's about do you have energy and is the
is your work depriving you of energy or
is your work generating energy for you
and you know there are people everybody
in this room knows people you who fall
into these two camps you're in a meeting
in the person comes in the room some
people come into the meeting and they
add energy to the meeting other people
come into the meeting and the whole
meeting just deflates and those people
just they they they drain energy from
the meeting and you have to decide which
of those kinds of people you're going to
be are you're going to add energy um and
the same thing at home and the same
thing at home and it's a so it's a wheel
it's a Cy it's a flywheel it's a circle
it's not a balance because a balance
that's why that metaphor is so dangerous
because it implies there's a strict
tradeoff and um you could be out of work
have all the time for your family in the
world but really depressed and
demoralized about your work situation
and your family wouldn't want to be
anywhere near you they would wish you
would take a vacation from them and so
it's not about the number of hours not
primarily I suppose if you went crazy
with you know 100 hours a week or
something yeah that maybe maybe there
are limits and they proba I've never had
a problem um and I think it's because
both sides of my life give me energy and
and that's what I would recommend that's
what I do recommend to interns and execs
do something you're very passionate
about and don't try to chase what is
kind of the hot Passion of the day I
think we actually saw this I think you
see it all over the place in many
different contexts but I think we saw it
uh in the internet World quite a bit
where you know at sort of PE speak of
the uh sort of Internet uh you know
Mania in say 1999 you found people who
were uh you know very passionate
something they kind of left that job and
decided I'm going to you know do
something in the internet because it's
you know was almost like the you know
the 1849 gold rush in a way I mean you
find that people uh if you go back and
study the history of the 1849 Gold Rush
you find that you know uh at that time
everybody who was in within shouting
distance of California was you know they
might have been a doctor but they quit
being a doctor and they started panning
for
gold and that that almost never works um
and even if it does work uh you know
According to some Metric financial
success or whatever it might be I
suspect it leaves you ultimately
unsatisfied so you really need to be
very clear with yourself and I think one
of the best ways to do that is this
notion of projecting yourself forward to
age 80 looking back on your life and
trying to make sure you've minimized the
number of regrets you have Jeff you've
built one of the greatest technology
companies in the world in just 20 some
years you've taken a company from
nothing to Amazon which everybody in the
world now knows and and most people in
the world seem to use was that harder to
do than trying to get a uh space uh
company off the ground which is more of
a challenge to you totally different
challenges so one of the things that uh
I find if I think back on the last 20
years you have to remember 20 years ago
I was driving the packages to the post
office myself in my 1987 Chevy Blazer
dreaming that one day I might be able to
afford a forklift and the internet
that's
1995 and you know 21 years later the
internet is this gigantic thing and
there are many many successful companies
and the entrepreneurial dynamism
that you see on the internet is
incredible and really with BL Orin you
know that this new challenge that I'm
taking on with BL Orin what I want to do
is put the heavy lifting infrastructure
in place so that the Next Generation can
have a a a dynamic entrepreneurial
explosion of ideas and inventions in
space just like we've had with the
internet and the reason you can't do
that today is because there's just too
much heavy lifting involved literally
you know getting to space is so
expensive and so hard when when we
started Amazon I didn't have to build a
logistics infrastructure system to
deliver Parcels there was something
already UPS already existed and the US
Postal Service already existed I didn't
need to build a remote payment system
there were already credit cards and
similarly you know there were computers
around and you know that didn't have to
get all those things would have been
tens of billions of dollar hundreds of
billions of dollars of infrastructure
the long-distance phone network became
the backbone of the internet but it
already existed and so you could have
this Dynamic entrepreneurial explosion
because all the heavy capex
infrastructure was in place for space
it's not like that the price of
admission is so high so that's the big
difference and what I'm super excited
about is lowering that cost I want to
dramatically lower that cost so that 20
years from now a new generation of
people with startup money real real
entrepreneurs small entrepreneurs can do
amazing things in space think how cool
that would be talk to me about long-term
thinking and your point of view on well
long-term thinking is a lever it lets
you do things that you could not do um
or couldn't even conceive of doing if
you were thinking short term so if I you
know that's why you know I have a
project where I'm I'm helping a group of
people build the a 10,000 year clock it
kind of ticks once a year and dongs once
a century and the cuckoo comes out once
a millennium it's a it's a big 500t tall
thing inside a mountain right here ins
one of those this mountain range and the
10,000 year clock is a symbol I don't
think it'll do anything for the first
few hundred years but after a few
hundred years once it's old people start
to pay attention to older symbols and um
so a few hundred years from now I hope
that people will think about that as a
symbol for long-term thinking if I you
know if if if I collaborated with
somebody here in this audience and I
said look I want you to solve world
hunger and I want you to do it in 5
years
you would properly reject the
opportunity you would say look it's not
possible it's not practical but if I
said look I want you to solve world
hunger in a hundred years that's a job
you'd take because it's a much more
addressable problem you can first create
the conditions you have time to create
the conditions where then you can solve
the problem and so that's that's a very
important way of thinking and um and I I
find and it's and it works with
everything I mean you have to back up
and find the right time Horizon for what
you're trying to do but you know at
Amazon we probably do most of our things
we expect that to get some results in
sort of five six seven eight years but
we find a lot of
our uh you know other companies that
compete against us in various ways
they're often trying to get things done
in you know two or three years and so we
can do things that you know if you if
you if everything has to work in two to
three years then that limits what you
can do if you give yourself the the
breathing room to say okay I'll I'm okay
if it takes seven years all of a sudden
you have way more opportunities how do
you encourage your employees to be
Innovative well this is a fantastic and
important question um to be Innovative
you have to experiment if you want to
have more invention you need to do more
experiments per week per month per year
per decade it's that simple you you
cannot invent without
experimenting and here's the other thing
about
experiments lots of them
fail if you know it's going to work in
advance it is not an
experiment and what happens in big
organizations that Amazon's a big
organization now too the Air Force is a
big
organization is that we start to
confuse experimentation with operational
excellence
so we you know operational excellence is
one of our four key principles at
Amazon we're building a fulfillment
center we've built over 150 large
fulfillment centers around the world now
we know how to do that that is not an
experiment if we build the 151st
fulfillment center and screw it
up that's just a failure
that's not the kind of failure we're
seeking we want failures where we're
trying to do something new untested
never proven that's a real experiment
and they come in all scale sizes so you
need to teach people that those two
kinds of failure are different um and
you need to have you said something
about that hard Middle where ideas don't
sure go up I think this is such an
important uh thing at Amazon one of the
things we try to do is have multiple
paths to yes if you want to be an
entrepreneur the most important thing is
to be customer obsessed so don't satisfy
your customers figure out how to
absolutely Delight them that is the
number one thing whoever your customers
are passion you have got to have some
passion for the arena that you're going
to uh develop and work in because
otherwise you're going to be competing
against people who do have compassion
for that and they're going to build
better better products and services you
can't be a mercenary you have to be a
missionary missionaries build better
products and services they always win
the mercenaries are just trying to make
money and paradoxically the missionaries
always end up making more money you to
pick something that you actually have a
genuine passion for you have to take
risk you have to be willing to take risk
if you aren't going to take risk if you
come up with a business idea there's
there's no risk there
you're
probably you know it's probably already
being done those ideas are already being
done they're being done well by many
many people so you got to have something
that might not work and so you have to
accept that your business is going to be
in many ways an experiment and it might
fail and that's okay that's what risk is
the good news is in Amazon we still take
risks all the time and we encourage it
and we talk about failure we should be
failing our failures have to grow with
the company we need big failures if
we're going to be moving the needle we
need to have you know billion dooll
scale failures and if we're not we're
not swinging we're not swinging hard
enough I um went to my boss and said to
him you know I'm going to go do this
crazy thing and I'm going to start this
uh this company selling books online and
this is something that already been
talking to him about uh in a sort of
more General context but then he said
let's go on a walk and we went on a
two-hour walk in Central Park in New
York City and the conclusion of that was
this he said you know this actually
sounds like a really good idea to me but
it sounds like it would be a better idea
for somebody who didn't already have a
good
job uh and he convinced me to think
about it for 48 hours before making a
final decision and so I went away and
and and was trying to find the right
framework in which to make that kind of
big decision and you know i' already
talked to my wife about this and she was
very supportive and said look you know
uh you can Count Me In 100% um whatever
you want to do you know it's true she
had married this kind of you know fairly
stable guy in a stable career path and
now he wanted to go do this crazy thing
but she was 100% supportive so it really
was the decision that I had to make for
myself and the and the framework I found
which made the decision incredibly easy
was what what I called which only a nerd
would call a regret minimization
framework so I wanted to project myself
forward to age 80 and say okay now I'm
looking back on my life I want to have
minimized the number of regrets I have
and you know uh I knew that when I was
80 I was not going to regret having
tried this I was not going to regret
having wanted you know trying to
participate in this thing called the
internet that I thought was going to be
a really big deal I knew that if I
failed I wouldn't regret that but I knew
the one thing I might regret is not ever
having tried and I knew that that would
haunt me every day um and so when I
thought about it that way it was an
incredibly easy
decision uh and I think that's a very
good it's it's if you can project
yourself out to age 80 and sort of think
what will I think at that time it gets
you away from some of the daily pieces
of confusion you know I left uh this
Wall Street firm in the middle of the
year when you do that you walk away from
your annual bonus and that's the kind of
thing that in the short term can confuse
you but if you think about the long term
uh then you can really make good life
decisions that you won't regret later
you don't choose your passions your
passions Choose You and I fell in love
with space and Rockets when I was a
5-year-old boy and watched Neil
Armstrong step onto the surface of the
Moon and I have been passionate about it
ever since and uh you know there's a
very real sense in which Amazon which is
an amazing uh fun
interesting uh company to uh to have
started in lead is you know a lottery
winning for me and so I'm taking those
lottery winnings and investing them in
blue origin um and I've been working on
that for 15 years uh our motto is gratum
ferociter which means step byep
ferociously uh I like to I'd like to do
these things very incrementally we have
uh uh there's a military phrase that I
especially love and it says slow is
smooth and smooth is fast and I have
seen that in every Endeavor I've ever
been in that's the kind of thing that
really allows you to make progress if
you do everything in the right sequence
never skip any steps um and so we have
been uh working in that vein for a long
time and uh stuff is coming out the
pipeline and I can tell you it's
incredibly gratifying we have uh now
more than a thousand person team uh at
Blue origin and that team is incredibly
talented and they're doing a great job
my vision for blue origin the long-term
vision is millions of people living and
working in space we need a space fairing
civilization for a whole bunch of
reasons and that's the vision if you
take the US Air Force One way to make it
nimbler would be to make it much smaller
but that's a really bad solution because
the scale brings so many
advantages and I see the same thing at
Amazon Amazon because of our scale we
can do things that we just couldn't ever
have done as a garage
startup you know there's some things
that only big organizations can do I
love Gad startups I was a garage startup
but you can't build a Boeing 787 in your
garage you need a big organization like
Boeing to do
that
so if we want scale we love scale and
you would never trade the skill of the
US Air
Force um uh for
anything but the question becomes how do
I keep the advantages of scale but still
have the advantages of a Nimble startup
how do I get the nimbleness too I want
to be able to absorb a
punch because of my scale and I want to
be able to dodge a punch because of my
nimbleness
well the the way you stay Nimble is by
making decisions fast in a 20 person
startup company the decision-making
speed is so
quick and that's why they're so
Nimble and then in a big company or a
big organization like the Air Force
course that decision making has a
tendency to speed the decision Mak you
get high quality decisions I think
sometimes people think the decisions are
low quality I don't think so I think you
usually get high quality decisions you
just get them slowly sure which is a
problem and so the way to fix that in a
larger organization this is what we do
at
Amazon is we acknowledge that there are
two types of
decisions there are
decisions that are we call them two-way
doors
there are decisions where if you you
make a decision you walk through the
door and it turns out you made the wrong
decision you turn around come back and
the consequence of that misstep is small
that's a type two decision that's a
two-way door decision there's a type one
decision where it's really hard to
reverse when you walk through that door
you have walked through that door and
it's going to be
expensive or impossible and time
consuming to reverse that decision so
you have to get that right that's a high
consequence decision those decisions
should be made deliberately carefully
slowly at Amazon I find myself on those
I'm the chief slowdown officer I slow
those decisions down like no I want to
see this one more way and the team's
working on it roll their eyes I've
already seen it 18 ways but I thought of
a 19th way and I want to see it that's
correct for a high consequence
irreversible decision you owe it to your
teammates to make those decisions stress
primarily comes from not taking action
over something that you can have some
control over so if I find that some
particular thing is causing me to have
stress that's a a a warning flag for me
what it means is there's something
that I haven't completely identified
perhaps in my conscious mind that is
bothering me and I haven't yet taken any
action on it I find as soon as I
identify it and make the first phone
call or send off the first email message
or whatever it is that we're going to do
to start to address that situation even
if it's not solved the mere fact that
we're addressing it dramatically reduces
any stress that might come from it so
stress comes from ignoring things that
you shouldn't be ignoring
um I think in large part so stress
doesn't come people get stress U wrong
all the time my opinion stress doesn't
come from hard work for example you know
you can be working incredibly hard and
loving it and likewise you can be out of
work and Incredibly stressed over that
so and likewise if you kind of use the
you know use that as an analogy for what
I was just talking about if you're out
of work but you're going through you
know a disciplined uh approach of you
know a series of job interviews and so
on and working to remedy that situation
you're going to be a lot less stressed
than if you're just worrying about it
and doing nothing I watched the moon
landing in
1969 uh when I was 5 years old and it
had a huge impact on me I remember I
could tell how excited all the grown-ups
around me were and I think by the way
that's one of the gigantic legacies of
Apollo is it inspired so many people to
enter science engineering
uh become Pioneers explorers uh and you
know it's it's I think hard be hard to
overstate the degree to which that
program did that for a whole generation
of people not just in the US but around
the world we did something as a
civilization that everybody had used as
a literal symbol of impossibility oh
yeah that'll happen when a man walks on
the moon and they had to change that
metaphor um in 1969 and so we all got to
witness that as a civilization and it
really made people realize the kinds of
things that we can do and um so I
definitely got that bug when I was five
and I kept after it and I did I read a
lot of Science Fiction as a kid I um
studied the science of Rocket engines
and propulsion and space vehicles and so
on and so on and the more you learn
about something the more you uh are
attracted to it because you once you
understand you start to understand some
of the nuances and the details and the
things that you really learn a lot about
become very appealing and so that
happened it's a virtuous cycle and by
the time I was in high school I was um
you know really uh on this journey of
knowing that I really wanted to be part
of someday figuring out how to uh help
build infrastructure and get people into
space and uh my girlfriend my high
school girlfriend has been interviewed
many times and she says there is no
doubt in my mind that Jeff started
Amazon just to get enough money do blue
origin um and you know you I can't prove
her wrong um so that is uh that's been
in my life I think we need
infrastructure to go to space the the
the real problem with doing interesting
things in space is that the price of
admission is so high that you can't have
that kind of entrepreneurial dynamism
that I witnessed up close and that all
of us witnessed happen on the internet
over the last two decades on the
internet in the last two is you can
start a company in your dorm room and it
can turn into a giant company that's not
metaphorical that's Facebook um I
started Amazon with a very small amount
of capital I didn't need much Capital
because all the heavy lifting had
already been done I didn't have to build
a transportation system to distribute
and deliver packages it existed it was
called the post office um I didn't have
to build a payment system it existed it
was the credit card and so on and so on
so when there is deep infrastructure
even if that infrastructure took many
decades and many billions of dollars to
build out people can stand on top of
that infrastructure and do amazing
things we don't have the infrastructure
to do that in space today if you're in
your dorm room you're not going to start
a interesting space company it's you
know the the starting price tags to do
really interesting things in space are
hundreds of millions of dollars going
quickly to billions but if we had
reusable space Vehicles then we'd be
able that would start to change
everything and you'd find a generation
later that you could have you know the
the two kids in their dorm room create
the Next Great Space company and then
you'd see thousands of space companies
and and you'd eventually get to you know
really amazing things going on
everything I've ever done has started
small um Amazon started with a couple of
people and um uh blue origin started
with five people and uh the budget at
Blue Orin was very very small now the
budget at Blue Orin is approaches a
billion dollars a year next year it'll
be more than a billion dollars so in
Amazon it literally was 10 people today
it's half a million people but you you
it's hard to remember for you guys but
for me it's like yesterday I was driving
the packages to the post office myself
and um hoping one day we could afford a
forklift and so but so for me I've seen
small things get big and it's part of
this day one mentality I like treating
things as if if they're small you know
Amazon even though it is a large company
I wanted to have the heart and spirit of
a small one and uh then so anyway that
the day one Foundation is going to be
like that we will will'll um we'll
wander a little bit too so I we have
some very specific ideas of what we want
to do but I believe in the power of
wandering all of my best decisions in
business and in life have been made with
heart intuition guts uh you know uh
not not uh an analysis um when you can
make a decision with analysis you should
do so but it turns out in life that your
most important decisions are always made
with Instinct intuition taste heart um
and that's what we'll do with this day
one foundation too it's part of that day
one mentality as we go about you know
building out this network of of of of of
nonprofit schools we will we'll learn
new things and we'll figure out how to
make it better my view on work like work
life balance is that I prefer the phrase
work life
Harmony um to me balance implies a
strict tradeoff and I have seen
situations where people are they have
all the time in the world maybe they're
out of work they have lots of time they
you know it's they don't they have all
all the time and they're so stressed
that they're actually terrible at home
everybody at home is like boy I sure we
should get a
job um and uh my sister-in-law says for
better for worse but not for lunch um
and so it's you you've you you really
want Harmony you want a um if you're
happy at work if you're finding meaning
in your work if you are um can be hard
they call it work for a reason it's not
going to be fun all the time that's a
pipe dream none of us enjoys every
minute of every day um and to have that
kind of idea would just be naive but
there should be fun at work you should
be laughing there should be moments of
Joy um and if you're getting energy from
work instead of your work draining your
energy then you're going to come home
and you're going to be a better mother a
better father a better wife a better
husband all those things you're going to
want to take out the
trash um and so even before being asked
that's what's going to happen Larry
she's going to say who is this
guy and so you really need to I think if
you're starting to get to the point
where you are worried about work life
balance I would challenge you to think
is just something out of whack it's
probably not the hours look you can if
you're working 120 hours a week you're
also doing something wrong that's too
much you it's not sustainable maybe you
can do that for a week or two but that's
it but if you're working you know 60
hours a week um that's completely
sustainable for most people and the qu
if you're burned out by it it's not the
number of
hours it's this it's you're doing
something wrong you need to figure out
what it is cuz you're going to going to
take that home and then your home life
is going to be stressful and then you're
bring that back into the office so it's
going to be a negative spiral and that
spiral will also be a positive one as
soon as you turn it around I think um to
some degree uh you follow your passions
and then wait the you know you have to
hope the wave catches you I was always
interested in
computers um I was always interested in
software uh I was always a big reader
and so so it wasn't you know which made
me alert to things like the internet um
and the possibility that you could build
a bookstore online that would have
Universal selection and that was really
the founding idea of Amazon and so I
think everybody has their
own uh passion their own thing that
they're interested in and then you're
very alert to the things
that that are in the sphere of influence
of that passion
so your passion has led you to change
the world frankly with Amazon but yet
you've got blue origin you've got
Basil's Explorations why can't somebody
like you just rest on your laurels
go well I you know I love what I do I
have um I also have four kids I have a
wife that I love I have a lot of
passions and interests um but I one of
them is you know at Amazon the rate of
change is so high and I love that I love
the I love the pace of change um I love
the fact that I get to work with these
smart big smart teams uh the people I
work with are so smart and they all
they're self selected for loving to
invent on behalf of customers and so you
know it's not uh do I love every moment
of every day no that's why they call it
work there's you know there's always
there are things that I that I don't
enjoy but if I'm really objective about
it and I look at it I'm so lucky to be
working uh alongside all these
passionate people and I love it why
would I why would I go sit on a beach I
did do a lot of soul searching I I went
to my boss at the time and I really
liked my job and I told my boss I was
going to go do this thing started an
internet
bookstore and um my wife had I'd already
told my wife and she's like great let's
go um and I I said to my boss I was
going to do this he's like this is a
good idea he say I think this is a good
idea but it would be an even better idea
for somebody who didn't already have a
good job and that sort of made some
logical sense to me and he convinced me
to think about it for a couple days so I
went away I was really trying to get my
head around how to think about this and
I think for me the right way to make
that kind of very personal decision
because those decisions are personal
they're not like data driven business
decisions they're they are you know what
does your heart say and for me it was I
could the best way to think about it was
to project myself forward to age 80 and
said look when I'm 80 years old I want
to have minimized the number of regrets
that I have I don't want to be 80 years
old in a quiet moment of reflection
thinking back over my life and and
cataloging a bunch of major regrets and
I think that regrets are biggest regrets
in most cases you can murder somebody
okay you'd regret that but in most cases
our biggest regret turn out to be acts
of omission its paths not taken and they
haunt us we wonder what would have
happened I loved that person and I never
told them and then they married somebody
else I did you know I didn't do this and
so that's the frame of mind that I put
myself in and I and once I did that once
I thought about it that way it was
immediately obvious to me I knew that
when I'm 80 I would never regret trying
this thing that I was super excited
about and failing if it failed fine I
would be very proud of the fact when I'm
80 that I tried and I also um knew that
I it would always haunt me if I didn't
try and so that would be a regret it
would be 100% chance of a regret if I
didn't try and basically a 0% chance of
regret if I tried and failed so I think
that's a useful metric for any important
life decision one of the great paradoxes
of inventing at a high level
is that you need to be an expert in your
domain area and you need to have a
beginner's
mind you absolutely need both of those
things the world is too complex to
actually just be a beginner so you know
I can't no matter how inventive I am I
can't go invent a new kind of brain
surgery you have to be a neurosurgeon
you have to already know all there is to
know about brain surgery and then take
it to the next level the problem is for
many people by the time they become true
experts they've lost that ability to see
things in a fresh way they've lost The
Beginner's mind and so that's another
thing you need always need to be
stepping back and saying if I I'm an
expert I'm an expert in launch vehicles
or whatever it is I I need to step back
and say
okay what if I were looking at this for
the first time what would I be seeing
and noticing these are just some of the
things you need to do to be Innovative
never chase the hot thing whatever it is
that's that's like trying to catch the
wave and you'll never catch it you need
to position yourself and wait for the
wave and the way you do that is you pick
something you're passionate about so
that that's the number one piece of
advice that I give to somebody who wants
to start a company or or start a new
Endeavor inside of a bigger company make
sure it's something you're interested in
something you're passionate about
missionary Aries build better
products and so I would take a
missionary over a mercenary any day
mercenaries want to you know uh flip the
company and get rich missionaries want
to build a great product or service and
you know one of those great paradoxes
It's usually the missionaries who end up
making more money anyway I talk a lot
about um willingness to be misunderstood
that's a really important thing to have
if you're going to do anything new or
different in the world it's is going to
be misunderstood sometimes by
well-meaning critics sometimes by
self-interested critics you'll get all
kinds um
and it's okay it's all part of the
process the only way to avoid criticism
altogether is to be completely
conventional in everything you do
and so how do you respond to the
criticism what do you do what's the
right thing to do well I think the first
thing you do is you
ask are the critics right you listen you
ask are they right or even if they're
not completely right is there some piece
of it that's right that you can be
inspired by and then if you decide by
the way that the answer is no that you
believe you have conviction that what
you're doing is the right
course then no force in the world should
be able to move you you should have a
deep Keel but if you decide that your
critics that there is something then you
should change um and I give you an
example from the early days of Amazon of
one where we refused to change this we
were small enough that most people
didn't pay much attention to us or care
about us I'm taking you way back to like
1995 1996 we pioneered this thing called
customer
reviews and I got a letter one day from
a publisher a book publisher that said
hey um you must not understand your
business business you're losing sales
because you're allowing negative
customer reviews on the book detail
Pages why don't you just put positive
reviews and I thought about this and I
thought no he's wrong we don't make
money when we sell things we make money
when we help people make purchase
decisions it was a different
Framing and so getting to today's news
um you know we listen to our critics
and we decided the framing that we have
been using all these years is
competitive compensation we look at what
other job opportunities there are and
what the competitive compensation levels
are and we offer competitive
compensation and actually
non-competitive World leading benefits
packages but just competitive
compensation
and so in light of this you know
thinking about this trying to decide do
we want to change change we realized we
just made a decision well you can offer
competitive compostition or you can
decide to lead and as soon as we framed
it that way we're like let's decide to
lead a great and I think people will
follow and what was it the critics said
that caught your eye basically they were
saying they were if you read between the
lines because a lot of the specific
criticism was not correct but if you
read between the lines what they really
wanted us to do they said because you
could also say look there's so many
companies all the fast food companies
there's you know the Baristas and
there's you know like wait a second why
are you focusing on us but that what
they're really saying is we're focusing
on you because you're a leader and we
want you to lead that's what they're
actually saying and as soon as you
recognize it that way instead of it
feeling like criticism it feels
empowering they're asking us to lead
because we're a symbol of an Innovative
iconic company we're a gold standard for
Innovation we should lead I was in our
all the senior um people at Amazon do
two days of customer service training
every other year and several years ago
now I was in one of those customer
service um training sessions and I was
taking calls from customers I had an
experienced customer service agent with
me listening in helping me figure out
how to use the tools keeping me out of
trouble Mak sure that I did a good job
for the customer and and um the customer
this particular call that I got the
customer as soon as we pulled up her
order the experienced customer service
agent leaned over to me and whispered in
my ear and said she's going to want to
return that
table she had purchased a piece of
furniture a table and I was and I so I'm
talking to the customer ser to the to
the customer and the customer says I
need to return in this
table and uh and uh it turned out the
the top of the table was scratched it
was packaged poorly and um and uh and
then so we finished up and we handled
the return and and got all that done and
I said to the agent how did you know
that the customer was going to return
that table say oh that table always gets
returned and so that what does that mean
that means that you know there's not
it's an anecdote but if you systematize
that and kind of pull back it means that
the that the uh uh there's no
communication flowing from these people
who are talking to the customers every
day back to our fulfillment centers
where the actual shipping and packaging
is going on and it's very difficult to
get that communication to happen it
can't just happen uh easily so we built
a kind of inspired by the idea of an
andon cord where any customer service
agent can pull a product off of the
Amazon website if they think that
there's a problem and then of course
that sets in that having pulled that
product off that sets in place a whole
series of uh processes that go back but
we're not going to ship the same table
to the same customer over and over just
find something that you're passionate
about I would definitely on the career
advice side the most important thing
about your first uh job out of school is
to pick a place where you think you're
going your where your learning per unit
time is going to be very high you can
optimize for a bunch of variables and it
can get very confusing you know where is
the location you know what's the uh uh
salary going to be and all those things
are worth considering they're all
important but make sure you pull back
after you've done your analysis and say
am I also picking the place that I
believe my learning per unit time is
going to be the fastest and you learn
much more from a best practices company
than you do you learn no matter where
you go so if you go work for somebody
you're like God these people are all
crazy this is insane you'll learn a lot
of negative lessons that you can use
later and you cannot do those things but
that process of elimination method takes
a long time um so it's better to try and
find a place that has really high hiring
standards some of the basics especially
you know a place that's trying to
recruit only the you know the you know
A's higher A's and B's higher C's and
C's higher D's so you got to hire only
A's and you need to pick a company
that's doing those kinds of fundamental
practices well because then you'll learn
so much it'll set you up to do other
things so I would say that's probably
the best career advice I can give there
are a couple of other things that are
essential for Innovation and invention
that are not as
fun one of them is you have to have a
willingness to
fail you have to have a willingness to
be misunderstood for long periods of
time if you do something in a new way
and I don't care what it is people are
initially going to misunderstand it
relative to the traditional way and they
will there'll be well-meaning
critics who you know genuinely want the
best outcome but they're worried about
this new way and there'll also be of
course self-interested critics who have
a vested interest in the traditional
they have some Profit Stream tied to the
traditional way um but but doing things
in if you want to if you never want to
be criticized for goodness sake don't do
anything new so it's it's it's okay
though if you have a willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you have a willingness to fail then
what you can do is you can ramp up your
rate of experimentation so successful
invention successful invention is
inventions that customers care about
it's actually relative ly easy to invent
new things that customers don't care
about um but successful
invention uh if you want to do a lot of
that you basically have to increase your
rate of
experimentation and that you can think
of as a process how do you go about
organizing your
systems
your people U all of your assets your
own daily life and how you spend time
how do you organize those things to
increase your rate of experimentation
because not all of your experiments are
going to work first of
all I love space I have been a space
lover since I was a 5-year-old
boy and I feel like I won the lottery
with Amazon I know I won the lottery and
uh and now I'm investing those lottery
winnings in blue origin which is uh the
space company um we built we're built we
are flying a a suborbital tourism
vehicle and we'll start taking people up
hopefully in
2018 it's coming right up working on it
for more than 10 years uh hopefully this
one this is this overnight success is
taking longer than 10 years I don't know
we'll see you know uh and we're also
building an orbital vehicle called new
Glenn new Shepard is named after Alan
Shepard the first American in space he
went on a suborbital journey new Glenn
is named after the American hero John
Glenn who uh was the first American to
orbit the earth uh and so uh these are
both these are reusable uh boosters
fully reusable that's the key to
lowering the cost our vision at Blue
origin is that we want millions of
people living and working in space and
my personal hope is that I live long
enough to
see um the kind of dynamism in space I
want to see a whole economy
entrepreneurs in space that I got to
witness the last 20 years on the
internet you know um the the problem
with being an entrepreneur in the space
arena is that the price of admission is
so darn high so it you know to do
interesting things in Space the
beginning you know kind of the beginning
entry level is a few hundred million
doar so you're not going to get you know
two kids in their dorm room doing
something amazing in space whereas
that's literally what happened to
Facebook right so on internet because
the price of admission is so low you can
get these amazing experiments where like
one kid in the dorm room does something
and it turns into Facebook and or you
know Amazon's case you know I started
this thing with an incredibly small
amount of
capital and the you know it was able to
grow because we didn't need a lot to get
to to begin with the heavy lifting was
in place for Amazon right so I didn't
need to build a transportation Network
it existed already it was ups and the
Royal Mail and the US Postal Service and
Deutsche Post and so on and so on I
didn't have to build a telecommunication
backbone to connect with my customers it
was there it was called the internet and
in fact the internet was resting on top
of the long-distance phone network at
that time you guys remember the dialup
modems some of you do some of you were
too young to some of you should go to a
museum and see a dialup modem what was
that
sound yeah and so I want I I recently
showed a group of youngsters a pay phone
I came across one and I was like my God
guys come over here this may be the last
one you have to see it um and uh so you
know the point is that Amazon was got to
rest on top of we didn't have to build a
payment system it already existed it was
called the credit card um computers were
already on every desk thanks to you know
Microsoft IBM and apple and you but what
were they being used for to play games
not to buy things on Amazon and so all
that heavy lifting was in place and I
want to you know my greatest uh uh uh I
would have such a good feeling if I
could be an 80-year-old guy and laying
there thinking about my life if I could
say look there is um now a bunch of
entrepreneurs in space because I took my
Amazon lottery winnings and built the
heavy lifting infrastructure that does
take billions of dollars in capex to
lower the cost
of access to space that's how you get
millions of people living and working
and by the way we need that for those of
you who like to think about the
future at all um you can do a simple
calculation you know we we can argue
about um you know what limited resources
on Earth and so on and so on but here's
a calculation that you cannot argue with
which is you take current Baseline
energy usage on Earth compound it at
just a few percent a year for just a few
hundred years and you have to covered
the entire surface of the Earth and
solar cells
so you have to we're going to have to
decide do we want a society of
pioneering invention expansion growth or
do we want a society of
stasis and personally I because the
Earth is finite and if you want a
society of stasis I think it's going
first of all I don't personally believe
that stasis is even compatible with
freedom so I think for me that's a big
problem
second of all it's going to be dull
stasis is going to be very dull you
don't want to live in the stasis world
and so of course we're going to continue
to get more efficient too we have been
for hundreds of years we've been getting
more productive more efficient that's
that trend is going to continue um but
even so we're going to want to use more
energy more energy per capita and also I
don't want to stabilize population I
would love for there be a trillion
humans in the source system with a
trillion humans we would have a thousand
Einstein and thousand mozarts it'd be an
incredible civil don't you want that
dynamism it'd be so much more
interesting my this is for your great
great great grandchildren but what kind
of world do you want them to live in I
want them to live in that expansive
world that is you know uh learning more
about the universe and moving out
throughout the source system so that we
have to do it and um anyway so it's fun
to work on that and uh uh uh you know I
get I have a a I won so many lotteries
in my life uh I have the best parents in
the world my mom Jackie and my dad Mike
my mom had me when she was 17 in
Albuquerque New Mexico she was still in
high school was not cool um and she did
an amazing job my dad Mike is a Cuban
immigrant who came here when he was 16
without his parents did an amazing job
so those are the things that are your
little gifts in life you get sometimes
you get my greatest admiration by the
way is withheld for those people and I
know several of them who had terrible
parents and still somehow made it
through that's hard um that I had the
opposite so I got lucky circle of
competence is is the
area uh in which certain kinds of
Industries for example I can understand
the future economics of other kinds of
Industries I I can't and and I have to I
have to know where that the perimeter of
that circle is now over the years I may
be able to enlarge the circle somewhat
but the circle never gets to be
all-encompassing and Tom Watson senior
who built IBM said I'm no genius but I'm
smart in spots and I stay around those
spots well he was talking about a circle
of competence and I see all of I you
know my partner Charlie says you know
it's wonderful to have a IQ of 180 as
long as you don't think it's 200 and I
have seen all kinds of very very smart
people self-destruct one way or another
in business or particularly in in in the
stock market and they they stray outside
of their circle of competence just
because they know they're they know
they're very very smart but that doesn't
mean they know everything and and
defining what your game is where where
you're going to have an edge is
enormously important and I think both my
partner Charlie and I have gotten
reasonably good at that over the years
all the early businesses that we own
together
disappeared they didn't disappear they
failed they failed yeah but but we took
so much out of them before they failed
that we it still worked out fine for us
we evolved them I mean but but but
literally the the three base
businesses all ended up disappearing and
they went out of business they didn't
they no longer fit into society in a
sense and actually the very first deal
that that we joined in on was something
called diversified retail which was in
Baltimore we bought an department store
there and we had Sandy goddess man had
10% Charlie had 10% and in his
partnership he had 10% and I had 80% in
our partnership and the three of us and
we always treated as you know we may
have had 80 but we were equal Partners
we had some terrific people were running
a force they were actually related to
s's wife uh and exceptionally honorable
people really honorable people and smart
if you're losing money in a business
with a smart decent person you know we
got a problem I mean that's the business
used a smart decent person to move them
over some other place and move the
capital some other place the company was
not yet losing money but we could see we
soon realized it was about to lose money
yeah and so we we we sold the apartment
store it went out of business in 19 83
but husters which was the Silk Stocking
Department start they went out of
business in I don't know 1985 or they're
they're gone and the people there quite
understandably wanted to build more
Branch stores but you don't want to put
more money into a a business that's
destined for value now we put $6 million
of capital in that and was a dumb
decision everything
but that 6 million what would it be
worth now Charlie at uh they got 4/10 of
a share great many billions oh it's tens
of billions yeah not the department
store had succeeded we'd have a nice
little business to send us a little
check but because because it failed
we've made 25 well we made more than 25
billion probably in that didn't look
like it at the time
though so when you realized it was a
mistake what did you do how how did you
address it we asked Sandy who was the
best salesman among us to go sell
it and we sold it and uh we put the
money into birkshire we got about 95% of
our money back yeah and we' borrowed $6
million in there so now we had that we
bought burer stock and we bought Blue
Chip stamp stock and eventually put it
all together it looked like a plate of
spaghetti at one time which was not good
as just complicated and so we we put
them all together and uh you know I've
still got stock and Charlie still got
stock that came out of Diversified
retailing as to a number of my partners
that uh from the old days best thing
that happened to us was that this place
failed obviously was a failure why what
did you learn me leave quickly yeah and
and use the capital
someplace Elsa I met Bob Woodward back
and and and and he' just come out with
all the president's man all of a sudden
as a below 30 years of age he was
getting quite wealthy and we had we had
the breakfast or lunch over at the
Madison Hotel he said what do I do with
this money and I said I said investing
is just about assigning yourself the
right story I said imagine Ben Bradley
this morning said to you what is the
Washington Post company worth what would
you do you have to write the story in a
month you'd go out and interview TV
Brokers and newspaper Brokers and owners
and you try and value each asset I said
that's what I do I assign myself the
right story and it's it's nothing more
than that now there's some stories I
can't write if you ask me to write a
story on you know what is some glamorous
but nonprofit making business worth I
don't know how to write that story but
if you ask me to write a story on what
is pic electric power Worth or something
like that I I can write the story and
that's what I'm doing every day I'm
assigning myself a story and then I go
out and so you get you made your first
investment when you were 11 years
old in 1942 80 years
ago I took $114 75 cents every penny I'd
say and I bought three shares of City
service preferred and City service was a
pretty wellknown name now and then in
fact in
1920 City service I think uh was the
fourth largest company in the United
States in terms of number of
shareholders and it was it was a big
company and uh uh so it had a preferred
stock that was selling a 38 that had
skip started skipping the dividends
during the Depression so it accumulated
dividends on it of 60 or 70 bucks and of
course it was part value of $100 too and
it was something at 38 and the breakfast
one morning I followed little stocks
every day but but then I made my plunge
and I had a roughly this amount of money
so I bought three I don't remember this
precisely but I think I told my dad in
the morning now let's move dad I call
but let's move pop but you felt the
thrill of it then for oh I've been I've
been reading about it and following it
uh the whole Mark I read I I I really
had read every book in the Y Public
Library that was on the stock market by
by 11 by 11 I'll guarantee you and some
of them twice uh I started out reading
the ones in my dad's office and and I
just love to read I'm wondering what
habit or habits have contributed most to
your ability to continue learning and
improving your investment decisions in a
changing business and financial
environment I would say that at least in
my case I haven't been continually
learning in terms of the basic
principles uh you always learn a little
more about given techniques or we learn
you know I learn more about some
Industries over time and therefore maybe
I've widened the universe in which I can
operate all more funds narrows it back
down unfortunately but I know more about
businesses than I knew 20 years ago or
40 years ago I haven't really changed
the principles the last change the basic
principles are still Ben
Graham they were affected in a
significant Way by Charlie and Bill
fiser in terms of looking at the better
businesses but they but I didn't leave
any of I didn't leave Graham behind on
that and I really haven't learned any
any new fundamental principles but I may
have learned a little bit more about how
business operates over time uh and
there's really nothing I mean you ought
to you you ought to get a investment
framework that comes straight from in My
View From the intelligent investor and
from Phil
Fischer uh more from the intelligent
investor actually and then I think you
ought to learn everything you can about
Industries and businesses that where you
think you have the ability to get your
mind around them if you work at them and
and with that Arsenal you'll do very
well and if if if you've got the
temperament for the business when I got
out of business school uh Columbia uh I
had a hero there named Ben Graham who
did wonders for me in all kinds of ways
in my life but uh when I got out school
I said um can I go to work for you for
nothing I was sort of hoping that if he
said yes he would then decide to pay me
but and uh and he told me that uh that
his little firm which only employed
about six or seven people that there was
so much much Prejudice then in in Wall
Street and Wall Street was divided then
between Jewish firms and and and Gentile
firms I mean there were a couple like
maybe that were known as Jewish
firms and there would be others that
were known totally as as as Gentile
firms and Ben said that because that
prejudice existed and he he'd
experienced it that he uh he felt that
to the extent that they had any
employment to offer with six or seven
people that they would uh they had hired
up to that point only Jews so I came
out to Al and sold stocks and said but I
kept pestering them for a while and a
few years later they hired me I was the
first Gentile hired long long ago people
don't even know about this but we own
two small insurance companies at
birkshire that
both went broke uh except we didn't let
them go broke I mean in other words we
could have walked away from them uh and
left money because they were separate
companies and we didn't walk away we
haven't spent our lifetime you know
working at things to try and figure out
ways to walk away from debts or have
things in IND dentures and play games
like they have you know with credit
default swaps to figure out ways to take
advantage of the the lenders it's just
not our game if we owe money we're going
to pay it back you said that it's it
would occurred to you both that it was
the more profitable way but that's
certainly not necessarily how the
majority of people in business think
it's the way our dads thought in both
cases who the hell knows where you get
your B from exactly but basically that
you know you have a few people that are
teachers to you in life that are not
formal teachers and the most important
people are your generally or your
parents and I never heard my dad say to
me in my life you know be sure you pay
all your debts but I just watched how he
lived and you want to have certain
people in life that you don't want to
disappoint you don't want to have people
that that make you a better person than
you otherwise would be and Charlie does
that for me now but my dad did it for me
early on I didn't know his dad but from
everything I've heard of about his dad
didn't he had the same experience I'm a
bright guy who's terribly interested in
what he does so I've spent a lifetime
doing it and I've surrounded my PE
myself with people that bring out the
best in me and you don't need to be a
genius in what I do that's the good
thing about it if I went into physics or
so i' a whole lot of other subjects I've
been also ran but I am in a game
that you don't need you probably
need 120 points of IQ you know but you
but 170 doesn't do any better than 120
it may do worse probably do worse but
but uh you don't really need brains what
do you need you need the right
orientation you know 90% of the people
I'm pulling a figure out of the air but
90% of the people people that buy stocks
don't think of them the right way they
think about something that they hope
goes up next
week and they think about the market as
something they hope goes up and if it's
down they feel worse I feel better and
you think
about and what do you think I think
about what company's going to be worth
10 or 20 years from
now and I hope it goes down when I buy
it because I'll buy more is business
school worth it depends on the person
and uh much more than it depends on the
school I mean I I wouldn't worry some
people are going to get a lot out of
advanced education and some people are
going to get very little and uh I I
don't even think it's important that
every person go to college at all I mean
we have all kinds of jobs that 70 or so
thousand a year 80,000 a year that
college training is is is not of use and
I actually was not keen on going to
college myself yeah my dad uh kind of
jollied me into it he could get me to do
anything but and if they' had an SAT
test in those days he would have taken
the test for me but I knew I could have
a good time and I I liked investing and
I didn't really feel I could read the
books you know it's it's a big
commitment to take four years and the
cost involved and maybe the loans
involved and everything I think
depending on what your interests are in
life uh I don't I don't think it's for
everybody I think it's for a lot of
people but there ought to be a reason
you're going and I didn't really see
much reason you have a competitive
Spirit clearly yeah clearly well but you
got to be you got to be careful about
what you compete in you know it's a good
thing I don't have a competitive Spirit
In chess know you know or football or
anything like that oh I just I'm I'm an
observer there I I enjoy watching things
like that but I I try to keep my
competitive spirit in a game wearing wi
do you have a Killer Instinct nah not
exactly I I've got I wouldn't call it a
Killer Instinct but I do I do know this
when I want to do something I always
want to do it big what that I put my
whole net worth in City service
preferred you know
$120
$14.75 I put my whole net worth in and
I've
never since I was well since that day in
you know March 11th
1942 I have never never had less than
80% of my money in American business you
can call them stocks orities but I see
them as American Business I I've owned a
piece of American
Business
for at least
80% at all times in you know I I just I
don't want to own anything else I I want
to own a home and you know things my
family wants and all that but owning
five homes doesn't mean anything to me
because I'm I'm going to be happy in one
home and there's a certain amount of
things that go wrong with everything and
if I got two homes i' I know I've got
more problems and I don't have more
happiness what brings you the happiness
oh
that I would have to be honestly say
that the that what makes me happiest is
what I'm doing what I'm doing you know I
I enjoy two things about it
one I know I'll win over time that does
mean I beat everybody else or anything
like that but I I I mean a game is very
very very easy if you have the right
lessons in your mind about what you're
buying I'm not buying stocks I'm buy
this is a overwhelmingly American
Business uh and I'm happy when that's
happy when that's uh when I'm doing it
I'm happy when stocks are going down I'm
happier when stocks are going down
because I I can buy more of them with
the same amount of money I'd be happy if
I was a farmer I'd want Farmland to go
down uh so I could buy more acreage you
know if I was I it just makes sense
there's two kinds of of items that
people buy and think they're investing
one really is investing and the other
isn't if you buy something a farm an
apartment house or an interest in a
business and look to the asset itself to
determine whether you've done something
what the farm produces what what the
business earns and so on uh you don't
really care where the stock market's
open you can do that on a private basis
in fact you do it on a private basis if
you buy a farmer apartment house
generally and it's a perfectly
satisfactory investment you look at the
investment itself to deliver the return
to you now if you buy
something uh like uh Bitcoin or or some
some cryptocurrency you don't really you
don't have anything that's producing
you're just hoping the next guy pays
more and the next and you only feel
you'll find the next guy to pay more if
he thinks he's going to find somebody
that that's going to pay pay the more
now if you ban trading in farms you
could still buy farms and have a
perfectly decent investment if you ban
trading in in apartment houses or even
in equities if you ban trading in
Berkshire Hathaway for the next 5 years
our investors would do fine you know
over time and but if you ban trading in
tulip bulbs you know or if you ban
trading in in some Bitcoin which nobody
knows exactly what it is uh people would
say well why in the world would I buy it
yeah and you aren't investing when you
do that you're speculating there's
nothing wrong with it if you want to
gamble somebody else will come along and
pay you more money tomorrow that's one
kind of game that is not investing it's
very important to surround your people
yourself with people that are the better
than you are you are going to move in
the direction of the people you
associate with so you you
constantly I I've been enormously Lucky
in that respect I mean I've i' I've just
had teachers and and friends and a
spouse that really was a better person
than I was and I had enough sense to
learn from these people that that life
went better if you behave better
yourself uh uh it took a while the uh uh
so I I advise
you to seek out as your partner in
business your partner in life whatever
it may be look for the people people
that
actually uh are examples to you rather
than somebody that you need to you think
you need to straighten out yourself and
simple rules like that delighting
customers working through other
people associating with people that will
will cause you to move in a better path
than you might otherwise have they will
take you so far in life that uh it it
it's hard to believe the secret is to if
you can in life work at what you love
with people you love and you know it
comes back at you love is something you
can't get rid of if you give it to other
people you get it back if you try to
hold on to it disappears I mean it's
unlike anything anything else in the
world and we literally we put on this
whole show we've got probably 3 to 400
people from our subsidiaries coming in
we have everybody in the world wanting
hotel rooms we've got them I mean you
know all the things that go with having
40,000 plus people come and having a
200,000 foot exhibition Hall and and
everything else and that basically is
handled by the people in our office
we've got 25 people in the office we had
25 last year we got 25 this year exactly
the same people not one change of a
person this is a company with 350,000 or
so people around the world working and
added 16 billion to sales last year but
we did not add a person and our CFO is
down there working I mean he is working
with projection or whatever they have up
there making sure this and that is right
everybody our tax the woman that is in
charge of our taxes you name it
everybody pitches in and they all have a
good time by far the best investment you
can make is in yourself I mean that for
example communication skills I tell the
students that come that they're going to
graduate schools and business and they
they're learning all these complicated
formulas and all that if they just learn
to communicate better both in writing
and in person they increase their value
at least 50 % I
mean uh if you can't communicate
somebody says you know it's like winking
at a girl in the dark nothing happens
you know basically and and you have to
be able to get get forth your ideas and
uh and that's that's relatively easy I
did it myself with the Dale Carnegie of
course some people wish I'd takeen a
shorter course now in terms my talking
later on but it it's just hugely
important and you if you invest in
yourself nobody can take it away from
you you don't
necessarily get it right the fir exactly
right the first time I mean the car
leasing business you know basically you
were competing on the cost of money to
finance cars and and it's very hard to
Delight a customer when you just give
him the car and tell them to send you a
monthly check for five years and you'll
be back at that time so his talents were
being wasted basically in that business
but at the age of 40 with all of that
experience behind him he found he
he he found the golden key and he he
took a very ordinary business and turned
it into an
absolutely extraordinary uh operation uh
and just like Mrs B or Rose blumpkin did
uh with
furniture
and the he didn't
worry about whether the Federal Reserve
was going to tighten or ease he didn't
worry about whether the stock market was
up or down yesterday you he didn't he
didn't worry about the things he
couldn't change but he did worry he did
focus on the one thing he could change
and that was the customer's experience
and I have
seen uh the one I didn't The One That
Got Away Enterprise I went down to
Florida and tried to talk him into
selling the Burkshire and he was smart
enough not to do it probably the value
of the company is quadrupled since I
made that visit uh but he he was smart
enough to see that he would find that
business Henry Ford as you may know
failed twice before he started the Ford
Motor Company in 1903 I mean the the
test isn't whether you get the greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you keep
learning as you go along what what your
strengths are and what you can do for
your customers what you can bring
especially to the party and to do
that uh you need you
need the
education that that I know you've
received uh through 10,000 small
businesses but you need a
genuine a genuine desire day in day out
to light the customer I've never I've
never seen a business and I've seen a
lot of businesses but I've never seen
one that Delights the
customer that that doesn't succeed I
mean what you want is that customer the
next day when they think do I want to
rent a car or do I want to buy some
furniture what goes through their mind
you know it's the place where they've
had a great
experience I don't know what I paid for
this type actually probably somebody
gave it to me but for the purposes of
the speech I will say I I have no idea
but what I or the shirt I'm wearing or
this but I do know I will remember how I
was treated when I bought it I mean you
long forget about the price but you
never forget whether you had a good
experience or a poor experience uh with
the purchase experience I don't know
where I'm going to invest next that's
what that's what makes my job
interesting I mean
I'm I'm I'm I'm not kidding I mean if
you went out and played golf and every
drive went in the hole you'd give up the
game wouldn't be interesting I mean what
what's interesting is when you get in
the rough and have to come out and a few
things like that so I I love the fact
that I don't know what I'm going to do
next you mentioned the Israel investment
in 2006 in the fall I got a letter from
a fellow and I never heard of him and I
never heard of the company he was
talking about but he said my name is Aon
wordheimer and I want to tell you a
little about my company isar the letter
was a page and a half long and he said
if he sold the company the family sold
the company the only company they wanted
to sell it to was Burkshire Hathaway and
if I was interested they'd be glad to
come over from Israel and explain it to
me and it was a it just jumped off the
page that that this was an interesting
idea so I emailed them and they came
over very shortly and and we bought the
business we we handed them $4 billion
for 80% of a company where I'd never
seen it or anything Aton kept saying you
got to come over to Israel and see the
plants and everything you won't believe
how wonderful they are and I said Aon I
don't go to council BL Iowa you know I
mean this I am doing fine in Omaha and
uh he said no no you got to see it I
said no no I don't I said we can make a
deal without seeing it he said well if
you buy if you buy the company well you
come and see it I said if we buy the
company I'll come so we bought the
company and I went over there and it's
true I've never seen plants like this it
was the greatest operation I've ever
seen and Aon said to me he said you know
that's why I want you to come over to
see these things I said listen Aton if
I'd come and seen them I'd have paid
more money
so so it uh we we have a wonderful
partnership with the people in Israel
but I don't know tomorrow uh our
partnership with the people in Brazil
with Georgie paemon and his associates
they are Sensational people uh I got to
know Georgie paollo when I was on the
port of Gillette with him and the
opportunity to buy into a wonderful
business like Hines and to be partners
and they do they'll do all the heavy
lifting they run the place uh with
Georgie Palin's Associates I mean it
it's just it's a it's a great
opportunity for us and I don't know what
the opportunity will be tomorrow with
Georg Apollo is last December uh I was
going out to Boulder Colorado where he
had a group that met and he said I think
I've got an idea might interest you when
I get out there and so I went out there
and and uh and as we came back on the
plane he explained what he was thinking
about in terms of hins and I said Count
Me In and uh uh and I will tell you one
other thing which is quite impressive
about him after I said that and went a
little little further in the thing he
sent me a
onepage governance description of how it
work would work between the two of us
and he sent me a very brief description
of what he thought would be a fair deal
for both of us I didn't have to change a
word I mean those are the kind of people
you like to associate with there are
lots of lousy businesses you know and
there's lots of wonderful businesses and
my job over the years has been to try
and figure out which is which and I've
made plenty of mistakes I bought a
company called Dexter shoes in the early
'90s I paid $400 plus million dollars
for it and it it made a lot of money
before I bought it but you know soon as
I bought it they pulled some switch or
something and it it immediately started
losing money and uh and it was because
of foreign competition so on or it was
maybe because I owned it I don't
know and it went to zero and the worst
thing was that I'd paid for it in stock
so that 400 million in stock I gave at
the time is uh now worth about five
billion so it it uh so uh every time
Berkshire stock goes down I feel a
little bit better because of my
opportunity loss on this business but
you know when I looked at Dexter shoe
they had a good position in retailers
they turned out good shoes they had a
great Workforce all kinds of things but
I just forgot one thing that that they
weren't going to make shoes in the
United States anymore so you make you
make mistakes and it does pay to
recognize quickly when you've made them
if you if you've got a good person
running a business and it isn't making
any money uh you know you're in the
wrong business and and you've got to
face up to that how do you deal with
failure and what's your advice to young
entrepreneurs like me in this case
especially with regards to failure and
how to approach it yeah well if you if
you fail you really do d yourself off
and you know get right back in I mean
you're going to fail at some things uh
uh you're going to have some Human
Relationships that don't work out uh you
know fairly significant number of people
get divorced I mean you know that's a
very big decision to to have turn out
badly but uh I think if you study almost
everybody and read read Kay's book you
know personal history and you'll
everybody fails at some things I mean
you know particularly particularly when
you're young I mean you know you you do
have less experience in evaluating
humans and you know and and just knowing
about whatever it may be businesses uh
but you know it is not fatal I mean if
you're healthy and you live in this
particularly living in this country
there's going to be there's going to be
an opportunity that comes along uh uh I
got turned down for the Harvard Business
School uh when I was when I got out of
the University of Nebraska you know and
I remember you know I went to Chicago to
get interviewed this is when you
traveled on the train and so I spent 10
hours going there and this B looked at
me in about 10 minutes he said you know
forget it Belle and now I got to go back
on the train 10 hours think what am I
going to tell my dad what what am I'm
going to tell my dad I mean my dad
always told me I could do anything you
and everything now I've just got just
gotten turned down uh you know but it
turned out be one of the best things
ever happened to me because then I went
to Columbia where Ben Graham was in fact
it it probably even affected who I
married because I took a onee course in
Columbia instead two years at Harvard
and she might have found some other guy
during that time and almost everything
in my life that looked like a failure
has either turned usually that's turned
into a success I mean it it it the world
isn't over you know if you have bad luck
in health that that's tough I mean that
there just no there just no getting away
I've been lucky on that but but the
other kind of things if you're healthy
and you're bright and you know you got
decades ahead of you you know if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know they're doing
things you don't approve of or they're
not treating you fairly you know the
world isn't over yet you know you just
go out and and find somebody else if you
were to do it all over again you're in
our shoes what industry would that be in
where would you start your own business
today i' do the same thing yeah I
mean for one thing I'd be a failure at
anything else probably I I'm not no I
mean I have had I had fun when I was in
my 20s my 30s now I'm 86 I'm having fun
and so I I advise students as much as
possible look for the job that you would
take if you didn't need a job I mean you
don't sleep walk through life and don't
don't say it's all going to be great you
know I'll do this and I'll do that and
you know I'm just marking time to get to
be older that I've told people that's
like saving up sex for your old age I
mean it just is not it it is not a good
idea yeah
yeah
what what are you urging them to do I'll
explain gu what I'm talking
about now it it you just yeah you really
want to be doing what you love doing and
you can't necessarily find it on your
first job but don't give up before you
find it you're lucky in life if you can
find your passion I tell the students
you know you may have to take a job or
two you you got you got eat but never
give up searching for the job that's
your passion try to find the job that
you would have if you were independently
Rich that's the job I have and when you
find that job the job that causes you to
be excited every day and forget about
the pay uh and where you associate with
people you love doing what you love it
doesn't get any better than that my
partner Charlie is 89 and we were
talking about that this weekend you know
I'm 82 he's 89 we do what we love every
day with people we love you know and
they seem to like us okay so it it you
know it it how can it be any better and
just Cost of Living does not equate the
standard of living and the standard of
living is you know achieving what you
want to achieve working with people that
you love and you don't need that much
money as I I love to ride around in a
private PL I will totally acknowledge
that leave leaving that out you know I
basically you know leaving out taxes and
charity and things like that I can live
on easily live on $100,000 a year and
and it and I wouldn't live I would live
better if I had eight houses if I had
you know a 400 foot yacht or anything of
the sort i' I've been on 400 foot yachts
and I've been a lot of fancy houses but
I'm in a house that I bought 55 years
ago it's warm in the winter it's cool in
the summer it has everything I wanted
plus it has all kinds of good memories
you know my my kids have good thoughts
about it I can't imagine living any
better I paid $31,500 for it I could pay
31 million for a house and and it
wouldn't it wouldn't do for me what this
present house does the most important
thing
uh aside from the things I've talked
about already is is really who you
associate with you want to associate
with people that are better than you are
I mean basically you'll go in the
direction of the people that you
associate with and and you want to have
the right Heroes uh you want people if
you want to emulate somebody you better
pick very carefully who you want to
emulate and uh and when obviously you
can't pick your parents uh uh they're
going to have an enormous influence on
you but you don't get a choice on that
but you get choices as you go down the
line and
you who you uh who you admire who you
who who you want to copy and the most
important for most people in terms of
that decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business but the partner in life is is
the most important one you you want to
pick a spouse that's that that's better
than you
are and then he or she and hope you hope
they don't figure it out too fast when
you get to my age you will not measure
how well you've done by how much money
you've got I can guarantee you that you
you'll all do fine on money anyway I
mean uh you know think about it 7 hours
a day you know you're in a bed you got
exactly the same mattress I've got if
you don't we'll sell it to you at the
furniture mark you know I mean so so
that I mean we're on a parity I can't I
can't outdo you you know in terms of my
sleeping enjoyment you can you can match
it by by buying the mattress which
will'll give you a special price on just
mentioned my name H we eat at the same
places you know we eat at Dairy Queen
particularly if you're in my position
because we own it but but weat at
McDonald's and Burger King and and when
I leave here I'll stop by a fast food
place on so our eating experiences are
the same we travel the same I mean I had
a 10-year-old car up till about a year
ago you know and it just doesn't make
any difference to me they they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the Super Bowl on big screen TV
you do it I I do it you know we dress
more or less the same I mean I pay more
for my clothes but they look cheap when
I put them on so we're really on a we're
on a parody yeah so so the money isn't
going to be that big a deal everybody in
this country is going to you know that
with the intelligence this group has the
energy you have you're going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts well I would say that you
will measure health is enormously
important and that's a matter of a fair
amount of luck I mean you know so I
won't I I don't want I'm not short in it
I'm just saying you can't do too much
about that but you will measure your
success in life by whether by how many
and extent whether it's the people you
want at 70 or whatever the age may be
you'll measure it by how many of them
really love you you know in the end I
mean you can't you know you you can't
buy love I mean it doesn't work you can
buy sex you can buy testimonial dinners
you can buy your name on buildings you
can do all kinds of things but the you
know the only way you get to be you know
love is to be lovable it's kind of
irritating actually if you got a lot of
money it'd be more fun to just write out
a check for a million dollars so
everybody you know from now on loves me
but it doesn't work that way and in fact
it it the only way is to be is to be
lovable and and you know I've got this
friend who uh who came out of owitz and
had at least one member of the family
die there and what is it now it's uh 60
years later you know she's still when
she looks at people it's a polish jew
when she looks at people the question
she asks herself in determining who she
really trusts as friends the one
question in her mind is would they hide
me now when you get to be 70 if you got
a lot of people that would hide you
you've had a successful life I know
people who have a tremendous amount of
money no one would hide their own kids
wouldn't hide them I mean they they
really wouldn't I mean their business
associates wouldn't or anybody else if
it really came down to it you know they
they don't have anybody's respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something of the sort but they
they nobody loves them and uh my friend
Tom Murphy at Camp City Stevie I mean
dozens of people would hide murf you
know all kinds of people would would
hide my wife you know that uh Ben Graham
A lot of people would have my my dad
would have had a number and then like I
say I can I can tell you people that uh
you know everybody May pay homage to
them and the kids may put up with them
and hope they don't change their will or
something but the truth is that nobody
would hide them and if you've got a lot
of people that would hide you when you
get to be
70 uh you will have had a very
successful life I just think part of
learning is failing but obviously when
you're getting started with something
you're not going to be an expert at it
immediately so you just need to to be
willing to go with that but I think this
is like I I don't know I mean maybe I've
just been embarrassed enough times in my
life yeah I I I do think there's a thing
where like you know as people grow up
maybe they don't want to be embarrassed
or anything they've built their adult
identity and they they kind of have have
a sense of of who
they they are and and what they want to
project and I don't know I think maybe
to some
degree you know your ability to keep
doing interesting things is your
willingness to be embarrassed again and
go back to step one and start as a
beginner and get your ass kicked and you
know look stupid doing things but at
running the company it's like we we just
take on new adventures and
um you know all the big things that
we're doing I think of his like 10 plus
year missions that we're on where you
know often early on you know people
doubt that we're going to be able to do
it and the initial work seems kind of
silly and our whole ethos says we don't
want to wait until something is perfect
to put it out there we want to get it
out quickly and get feedback on it and
so I don't know I mean there's probably
just something about how I approach
things in there but I I just kind of
think that the moment that you decide
that you're going to be too embarrassed
to try something new then you're not
going to learn anything anymore we have
a lot of competitors um in pretty much
everything we do from social media to
devices to advertising to like all all
the different areas but I don't know I I
guess one philosophy that I've always
had is I actually think your
biggest the thing that determines your
destiny is not a competitor it's how you
execute um and I think
most most companies
probably Focus too much on competitors
and maybe even focus too much on ideas
and I think at the end of the day a lot
of what makes great companies Great is
the ability to just like relentlessly
execute and efficiently execute and do
that rigorously and just get better and
better at it all the time and that's one
of the things that we've really focused
on so I don't know maybe it's like um
it's sort of like a very I don't know
like martial arts view of the world or
something that you um you know it's like
when you go into a competition it's not
you're not fighting another person
you're fighting yourself right and
you're you're just trying to be a better
version of yourself and make the company
better and able to better execute um
every day in a world that's
changing so quickly the biggest risk you
can take is not taking any risk and I I
really think that that's true right I
mean a lot of people I think think that
um you know whenever it comes whenever
you get yourself into a position where
you have to make some some big shift and
in direction or do something um you know
there always people are going to point
to the the downside risks of that
decision and locally there're may be
right right I mean for any given
decision that you're going to make
there's upside and downside but in
aggregate if you are stagnant and you
don't make those changes then um then I
think you're guaranteed to fail right
and not not catch up so to some degree I
think it's really right that over time
the biggest risk that you can take is to
not take any risks so many things go
wrong when you're starting a company and
often I think people ask you know what
mistakes U should you avoid making and
you know my answer to that question is
don't even bother trying to avoid
mistakes because you're going to make
tons of mistakes right and the the um
the important thing is actually learning
quickly from whatever mistakes you make
and not giving up right and I mean there
there are things every single year of
Facebook existence that could have
killed us or made it so that it it just
seemed like moving forward and making a
lot of progress just seemed intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and um nothing is impossible you
just have to kind of keep running
through the walls let's talk about the
the training yourself to be
uncomfortable or to become more
comfortable with discomfort does
anything come to mind just in terms of
managing your psychology for my own
psychology the way that I try to manage
this stuff is I wake up at the morning
and you get like whatever emails you
have of like stuff that's going on in
the world right so it's it's world
events it's team events whatever Trends
we're seeing across our our products and
often in there there's a fair amount of
bad news and like new things that I need
to absorb one of the things I found that
just just for kind of managing my my
myself is that if I try to just go
straight into the day it's like almost
every morning when I wake up and like
read read through my my emails and get
the news it's like it's almost like
getting punched with sort of like a ton
of new context and it's like okay I need
to like internalize this so I found that
basically doing something physical and
and something that's like meditative to
take my mind off of it for like an hour
so then I can reset and go do work is
really important so that's why you know
things like foiling or surfing have been
really important to me because you know
when you're out there in the water it's
like pretty hard to focus on anything
else right it's I mean it's like you
when you're on the board you you you're
focused on making sure you stay on the
board and don't mess something up you
know especially if you're if you're kind
of towing or something like that there's
not a whole lot of downtime yeah I found
that for my own performance is
significantly better when I have
something like that that's like
meditative and and physical and and
allows me to kind of output some energy
and then I can come back in and it's
almost like I'll have subconsciously
settled all of the things that that have
sort of all all the news that have
happened in the world now it's like okay
let's go deal with it yeah now obviously
if there's something that's really an
emergency I'm not going to you know go
do a sport or something I'll I'll go
deal with it and and obviously part of
life is you you don't always get to
control your schedule and and that's
kind of how that goes but you know when
I compare kind of how I do on the days
when I kind of get to have some time to
soak that in or or to to kind of have an
outlet versus just like jumping right in
I I find I'm often like stewing in bad
news or something and then I just I I
like I'm not I'm not as productive so I
think that's sort of my own personal way
that I try to to manage situations like
this but obviously a key part of this is
like having an awesome team and and it's
not it's not you know primarily about me
at this point you know it's a big
company and we have awesome people who
are who are running all these different
groups so I get that the what I'm what
I'm saying kind of how I've worked out
this system for myself isn't necessarily
something that would work for a lot of
other people companies are are learning
organisms and you can make decisions
that either make it that you learn
faster or you learn slower and you know
a lot of ways building a company is like
following the scientific method right
you you try a bunch of different
hypotheses and if you set up the
experiments well then you kind of learn
what to do and I think that's that's an
important philosophy so there are all
these different decisions that we make
inside the company you know everything
down to um really empowering individual
Engineers we we invest in this huge um
testing framework right at any given
point in time there aren't there's not
just one version of Facebook running in
the world right there's probably tens of
thousands of versions running because
Engineers here have the power to um to
try out an idea and and ship it to you
know maybe 10,000 people or 100,000
people and then they get a readout on
how U that version of what they did
whether it was um a change to you know
show better content in Newsfeed or or UI
change or some new feature they get a
readout on how uh that version performed
compared to the Baseline version of of
Facebook that we have on on everything
that we care about how how connected
people are
um you know how much people are sharing
and how much they say that they're
finding meaningful content um business
metrics like how how much revenue we
make and an engagement of the overall
community and you know by running tens
of thousands of of different experiments
and and putting the power in people's
hands to try all these different things
you can imagine we just make so much
more progress than we could if every
change had to be approved by me right or
or any every idea had to come from from
management so I do think that there's
something very deep about building this
you know learning culture and moving
quickly towards that that just helps you
get ahead over time to me
entrepreneurship is about creating
change not just creating companies and
you know the the most effective
entrepreneurs that who who I've met care
deeply about some mission and some
change that they're trying to create and
often they don't even start because
they're trying to create a company right
and you know that's how how I think
about um you know my connection to to
all of us here is when I was getting
started I
you I wanted I car deeply about giving
everyone uh a voice and giving people
the tools to share everything that they
cared about and uh bringing a community
together and you know it started small
in in one
University and I didn't think it was
going to be a company at the time um as
a matter of fact I was pretty convinced
that at some point someone would build
um something like this for the world but
uh you know I thought that that would be
some other company that you know already
had thousands of Engineers and was used
to building stuff for hundreds of
millions of people around the world and
you know what ended up happening was um
you know that no one built it right so
we just kind of kept on going right I
mean people said it each step along the
way um you know what you're doing all
right maybe college students like it but
no one else is going to like it and you
know there's not going to be any money
in doing this so all right so you only
really do it if you care right if you're
passionate about doing it and you then
it started growing and people said it
would be a fad and it would never be a
good business but you know you keep
going because you care uh not because
you're you're trying to create a
business um and you know then there's
the shift to mobile where people thought
that it wouldn't be a sustainable
business and um you know through each of
these things you the the the
entrepreneurs who I think build things
that last for a long time keep going
because they care fundamentally about
the change that they're trying to create
in the world um and they're not in it
just to to build a company doing the
Rebrand when you did and did it achieve
what you hoped it would
well yeah no I think that that's that is
a good place to start um I'll I'll I'll
just start off by saying that you know
about a year ago this time you gave us a
lot of trouble by uh by breaking the
news of of of this Rebrand so um sorry
about that well you know it's you were
doing your job and and I respect that so
I appreciate that um but I I think that
that was that was just about the biggest
thing of the year that we were trying to
we did tried so hard to keep it under
wraps but but somehow you got that one
um so touche um I I there's a bunch to
reflect on here so first is this is a
long-term Journey right I mean it was it
was never like okay we're trying
to the internal conversations we
had actually always expected that the
initial moment of the Rebrand was going
to be quite negative and um and that
over time we would just sort of build
this out right just because like there
are all these questions around what the
Future Vision is that we're building and
um and we just and and all the stuff is
ahead right I mean we're kind of this is
the you know the first version of the
the work VR device line that we're
shipping and you know it's not going to
be until you know later this decade when
we're on V4 V5 that this stuff really
starts to get fully mature and um so I
just figured there's so much story here
left to fill out and this is like a
long-term thing so I'd say the initial
response to the Rebrand dramatically
surpassed my expectations about um kind
of what could be achieved in terms of
people um
hearing the vision that we were that we
wanted to put out there and I think like
almost overnight um you know in the
first few months you had all these other
companies sort of um jumping in and and
talking about how they wanted to do
stuff in the metaverse too and I think
it really popularized um that term and
that Vision um in a way that that just
dramatically exceeded what id actually
expected in the business world really
everywhere and now there's Chief
metaverse officers at companies
right I mean you sounds like you didn't
expect for it to catch on quite like no
I I kind of assumed that we were going
to have to just continue building out
the road map and that I mean maybe
sometime like 5 years from now things
would start to click and people would
start to understand what we were putting
together um instead I I I think a lot of
people really got a lot of the vision um
for for what it is I mean obviously it's
still this high level concept and
there's a ton of stuff that still needs
to get built but but I I I think you
know it caught people's excitement um
just as as sort of a kind of a long-term
hope for what we want to build more than
more than i' I'd actually thought was
possible um and that I think actually
poses different opportunities and
challenges on the one hand um a lot of
folks are really excited about working
on it on the other hand I do think it
just sets up for a a trough of
disillusionment at some point because
you know it is a vision that's that's um
that's far out um and and we're
obviously investing a lot and the
products are working really well I mean
Quest 2 is is working really well um you
I think a lot of the research that we
have and mixed reality augmented reality
neural interfaces like all the all these
I I think these are leading in in across
the industry so I'm really excited about
what we're doing but um but it's not
like the stuff is going to be fully
mature in in um you know in a year or or
even you know two or three years it's
going to take a long time to build out
the next Computing platform um so so
we'll see in running a company for you
know almost 20 years now one of the
things that's been pretty clear is when
you have a team that's
cohesive you can get
almost anything done and you know you
can you can run through super hard
challenges um you can make hard
decisions and push really hard to to do
the best work even you know and kind of
optimize something super well but when
when there's that tension I mean that's
that's when when things get really tough
and you know when I talk to other
friends who run other companies and
things like that I think one of the
things that I actually spend a
disproportionate amount of time on in
running this company is just fostering
in a pretty tight Core group of of
people who are running the company uh
with me and that to me is is kind of the
thing that both makes it fun right
having having you know friends and
people you've worked with for a while
and new people and New Perspectives but
like a pretty tight group who can who
you can go work on some of these crazy
things with um but to me that's also the
most stressful thing is is when when
there when there's tension um you know
that's that that weighs on me I I think
the you know just it's it's it's it's
maybe not surprising I mean we're like a
very people focused company and it's the
the people is the the part of it that
that um you know weighs on me the most
to make sure that we get right but yeah
that that that I'd say across everything
that we do is probably the the big thing
you did personal challenges annually for
about 10 years which which challenge
ended up being much easier than expected
and which one ended up being much harder
than expected either or just be curious
to know I still do stuff like this I
don't
like make as big of a deal of it anymore
but I I mean but I think just kind of
throwing yourself into different
situations to learn new things is I
don't I think that that's just a big
part of life so yeah well which ones
were hard one I tried to meet a new
person every day for the year that was
hard for me I'm pretty introverted I
built some amazing relationships out of
it I you know I started
teaching this class at the local boys
and girls club with a friend and like
mentored the kids for just talked to
them a couple weeks ago they were all
like none of their families had gone to
college before and now they're all
graduating college it's pretty cool
that's amazing but I'm super introverted
so I think that that's probably been
another silver lining of the whole
distributed work thing for me is having
space to to kind of think and and kind
of control my my time and like not not
get interrupted by other people so much
but it's an interesting balance being
introverted but also like being pretty
sensitive and caring a lot about other
people I think that the people kind of
think that that introverts are like you
know for like don't like other people or
something that's not true I just just
get overwhelmed easily yeah and then
some of the ones I the interesting thing
is they all went in weird directions
right so one year I did this like year
of running and then it's like I just did
all kinds of different running I did
like Sprints I did longdistance running
and then like my started hurting then I
broughten down and did triathlons and
training for this Iron Man but then I
like I broke my arm biking so that ended
up not quite happening so I mean they
all kind of go in in different
directions you I learned Mandarin one
year learned Mandarin you can't learn
Mandarin one year it's challenging one I
mean maybe someone can I cannot um you
know we talked about my language
deficiency earlier on but I that was
partially I like I like kind of throwing
myself into things that that are hard
and you know like like I said before I
mean I've studied a lot of languages and
in my life a little Spanish a little
French a little
Hebrew a lot of Latin a bunch of Greek
but it's it's actually hard for me so I
kind of like doing things that are hard
for me the meaningful social
interactions shift that we made was when
we started seeing this trend that
basically people were starting to
comment less at the same time people
were watching more video and especially
longer form video was displacing um a
bunch of content from um from friends
and people we're actually writing it and
saying hey I'm missing stuff for my
friends because I'm watching all these
videos so we're like okay two things
that we want to do one is we want to
make sure you're not missing content
from your friends because that's like
that's what we're here to do right it's
um yeah you can you can find some
entertaining videos um here and you can
do that in other places too but you're
not going to find that the content from
your friends and in other places so we
want to make sure we're we're um we're
doing that well um so that was the
comment that I made around even if we
show less video and time spent goes down
which which it did um that still seems
like a good thing over time because
we're here to help you interact um we
did put in place a set of changes around
um and we're constantly evolving the the
algorithm and way that feed works but um
but at the time um we wanted to make
sure that it wasn't changes that we were
making that were basically leading to
the the this um Decline and and
commenting in in line um so we wanted to
make sure that we were building feed and
optimizing for people interacting not
just viewing content and passively
consuming it um and and I want do you
feel like the discovery engine will get
people to consume more passively is that
a concern for you well no because the
the thing that I'm saying which is that
most of the meaningful interactions at
this point are shifting to messaging
right so um what we see is if we build
feed in a way that isn't necessarily
trying to optimize the amount of time in
feed but the the kind of engine that's
driving that thinks that okay if if if
if I if I show you a piece of content
and you think it's interesting and let's
say you don't do anything in feed but
you send it to a friend and then have a
message throw there like if that's good
you can go towards that yeah yeah I
think that that is good right so so I I
I think that the initial push towards I
think what is kind of technically in the
in the Press called the MSI chain from
my perspective was more of this sort of
shift in in feed that we've evolved
towards and and continue pushing on um
no I I think that that like reflects the
values of the company it's like of
course we want to we want to have feed
lead to more interactions between people
and not just passive consumption of
content but I think you also want to
make sure that we're being Dynamic about
like what are the ways that people are
actually interacting phase one is build
a thing that kind of Sparks some joy and
that people appreciate then from there
you want to get to something that is
retentive that way people who have a
good experience with the thing come back
um and and want to keep using it and
those two things are not they're not
always the same a lot of there are a lot
of things that people think are awesome
but may not you know always come back to
I mean I think you know some of what
people are seeing now around like chat
GPT is part of that it's like I mean
this is like like this level of AI is
it's like a miracle right it's awesome
but I mean that doesn't mean that
everyone is going to have a use case
every week right so so I think that
there's first is like create the spark
second is create the retention
then once you have retention then you
can start encouraging more people to
join but if if people aren't going to be
retained by it why would you ask people
to go sign up for something right um so
kind of Step One spark step two
retention step three growth and scaling
the community and then only at that
point is step four which is monetization
and I mean we can we take a while to go
through all those I mean we're really in
in some sense only getting started on
the monetization of um the messaging
experiences like WhatsApp now with stuff
like business messaging two billion
people use the product every day right
so it's I mean we we like we scaled it
pretty far um but I think with our model
that that sort of works so I'm always
very focused on people
and I think the most important decision
you're probably going to make if you're
in college is who you surround yourself
with because you become like the people
you surround yourself with
and I sort of
have this hiring heuristic at meta which
is that I will only hire someone to work
for me if I could see myself working for
them not necessarily that I want them to
run the company because I like my job
but like but but in an alternate
universe if it was their company and I
was looking to to go work somewhere um
would I be happy to work for them and I
think that that's a helpful
heuristic to help balance you when
you're building something like this
there's 's a lot of pressure to you you
want to build out your teams because
there's a lot of stuff that you need to
get done and you know everyone always
says don't compromise on quality but
there's this question of okay how do you
know that someone is good enough and I
think my answer is I would want someone
to be to to be on my team if I would
work for them um but I think it's
actually a pretty similar answer to like
if you were going to go if you were
choosing friends or a partner or
something like that so when you're kind
of in college trying to figure out what
your circle is going to be trying to
figure out you you're evaluating
different job opportunities um who are
the people even if they're going to be
peers in in what you're doing who are
the people who in an alternate
University you would want to work for
them because you think you're going to
learn a lot from them because they know
because they they are kind of values
aligned on the things that you care
about and they're going to like um and
they're going to push you but also they
know different things and have different
experiences that that are kind of more
of what you want to become like over
time so I don't know I think probably
people are too in general objective
focused and maybe not focused enough on
the connections and the people who
they're who they're basically building
relationships with there's this culture
in Silicon Valley that kind of makes
startups seem glamorous and I never
really believed that right I never had a
goal of starting a startup and my goal
when I realized that I had a company was
to get it to be a good company as
quickly as possible right and kind of
get of what you'd call the like risky
startup phase where you are just like
constantly about to die and where you
could get to a point where you can
actually do some interesting things and
make make a lot more interesting bets
and um so I don't know I I never read a
lot of the literature on this and I mean
maybe if I had then I wouldn't have made
so many mistakes but so I don't know if
like if learning for me is the right way
to go on this but I mean but it did I
think your model must have come from
somewhere though even if it was even if
you it was unintentional right like were
you influenced by Peter teal or Sean yes
I was influenced by all these people
once I met them I actually I hadn't
really heard of Peter teal before me
yeah right yeah but I mean he was
massively influential on my thinking
right I mean I like a lot of the um the
early lessons that I took on how to
think about strategy came from Peter and
Sean and um I did pay a lot of attention
when I was growing up to Microsoft I
thought I mean I grew up you know using
you know Windows 3.1 and then Windows 95
and I just thought that those were like
the most unbelievable things and um
sense they are yeah they really really
were awesome right um well I I don't
know if you you meant that positively
but I did um and and I thought you know
building this ecosystem was really neat
and that kind of inspired me right in
the way that they built a platform I
kind of thought okay well maybe one day
you know the the tools that I'm building
can be part of a broader ecosystem as
well what would you say is the hardest
part of running
meta
um well I think the hardest
this may just be for me because of the
way that I'm oriented but
um you know it's a big company and I
think getting the people right and the
culture right is the thing that both
matters the most and is sort of the
hardest to dial um you especially as a
company scales and um one of the things
that I found over time is you know we've
gone through these different periods as
a company where know sometimes people
think we're awesome sometimes people
think we're terrible um you know
sometimes people think we're just like
everything we do is going to be a winner
and sometimes people think like we're
like the gang that can't shoot straight
and like you know we we you know just
nothing that we do is going to work but
regardless of what people are saying
externally I found that if you can keep
sort of a a good amount of internal
cohesion you can get anything done right
whereas even when you know sometimes
people are very excited about the
company if people internally aren't
actually aligned on what we need to go
do then it's very hard to get things
done so um for me I mean it's it's maybe
somewhat of a of a trite thing to say
but I think like I mean this is all
about getting people right to like and
getting the right people to to involved
and building great teams of of awesome
people to um to be able to build you
know new things that are super
impressive for a lot of people so that's
that that to me is is probably what I
spend the most time focused on
and um and I it's probably the most
important part of running a company
we've had this tradition for I don't
know probably seven or eight years at
the company uh where every week uh we
have a Q&A where um where our employees
can come and ask me any question that
they want about what's going on and um
what the what the direction of the
company is or questions or things that
they read about in the press or that
their friends who use the product um
what what they're asking them and um and
it's been this really important
tradition for us um both because we
really believe in in openness and
communication and that's kind of what
Facebook is all about uh but it's also
really important for for me and for um
running the company to be able to get
feedback right and and to be able to
learn what's on people's minds um what
our what our employees and folks um who
who are who are part of our team are
thinking about and um and just kind of a
lot of the time there are good questions
that people ask that change the way that
we that we think about what we're
building and what we're here to in the
world and um that often make us go think
and reevaluate um how we should be
approaching different problems I don't
hire people who I wouldn't work for
myself I think that's a really good
heuristic because everyone knows this
like there's this saying like a players
hire a players and B players hire C
players which is like good people hire
good yeah um and I don't think that
that's that informative right because I
mean what are you going to say like do
someone in your organization player you
don't get to hire people like I mean no
I mean um and and I think a lot of the
time the problem is you don't actually
know and sometimes you're like trying to
figure out how good someone is if you
didn't think they were good you wouldn't
have hired them but theistic of only
hiring people who you would work
for um tends to be pretty good I think
because then it's like then that you
know right it's like I would not work
for this person then okay I'm not going
to like stretch just because I need to
fill a role today I actually I spent a
bunch of time analyzing and and
reflecting on why it was that we were
even able to do it because all like all
reasons suggests that we shouldn't have
been able to do it right because all
these other companies had way more
engineering power and um and and servers
and time and money and all this stuff
and I actually think that this is a
pretty instructive thing for anything
that you want to go do because this is
the same property is going to be true
for any that you guys start is that
someone else is going to have more
resources and be able to do it the
reason why I think we actually ended up
being the ones doing it is because we
just cared way more about it than
everyone else right so there were always
projects at some of the these other
companies that were these Hobbies but we
always thought that it was this really
important thing and really just like
felt in our gut and our heart that we
wanted to do it and you know early on
there were always these Skeptics saying
that oh this can't be a business we
didn't actually care that much about it
being a business early on uh but a lot
of the reason why bigger companies
didn't invest in it was because it
wasn't clear that there was a model that
would work for it it seemed like a bad
idea yeah and I actually think that
that's true for a lot of the best ideas
right is that it's not that someone else
can't do it they actually can and the
odds are stacked against you but I think
often that belief in the fact that you
just care so much about what you're
doing is the only thing that kind of
drives you to do it and you know to be
honest that kind of drives me to this
day I mean one of the the big emphasis
uh points for the company right now is
internet.org and you know for a while we
had this rallying Cry of can we connect
a billion people um and you know when we
start talking about that we thought that
was crazy right it was way bigger than
any service in in the world that had
been built and you know it was 10 digits
long right it's like a you know it just
it felt crazy we'd never get to that but
then the thing is as we started to
actually get closer to that we took a
step back and we're like all right well
our mission isn't actually to get one in
seven people in the world to be
connected it's we want to connect
everyone so it's um it's a big issue
that only around a third of the people
in the world have access to the internet
and that's something that we think that
we can do something about and similar to
early Facebook we don't there's no
business model around this I mean all
the people who have all the money in the
world I mean it's not necessarily a fair
thing are already the people who on
Facebook right it's in the first you
know seventh of the world um but we just
believe really strongly it's like this
is what we are here to do um this is
what our company cares about I care
about it the team cares about it our
culture cares about it so we're just
going to keep pushing on it and I
actually think a lot of the reason why
great stuff gets built is because it's
kind of irrational at the time um but so
it kind of selects for the people who
care the most about it doing it ideas
don't come out fully formed they only
become clear as you work on them you
just have to get
started if I had to know everything
about connecting people before I got
started I never would have built
Facebook movies and pop culture just get
this all wrong the idea of a single
Eureka moment is a dangerous lie it
makes us feel inadequate because we feel
like we haven't had ours
yet and it prevents people with seeds of
good ideas from ever getting started in
the first place you know was n so so
long ago that you know I was a student
and you know sitting in in a seat in an
auditorium like you guys are here today
um listening
to I remember very specifically this
time when Bill Gates came to talk at at
Harvard and um I just like wow how do
you how do you do that um
and um but you know the trick is is that
the media likes to send sensationalize
this as if you have some Eureka moment
or you are some singular person who
can't build something on your own and
that's just not how the world Works um
you know when I was in school I built a
lot of stuff that I just like building
um there was not a single moment when I
when I had some Revelation that Facebook
was going to be awesome uh that's not
maybe how the media or movies or
whatever would like to uh portray things
it's not it's much less exciting but the
reality is I think
most services in the world that reach
the scale that Facebook has um you start
off building something that you care
about and you know you don't necessarily
think it's going to be that big I I
didn't um you know I built Facebook the
first version of Facebook uh for my
College Community because I wanted to be
able to connect with the people at my
school and and I remember very clearly
talking to my friends at the time and
saying you know it's how cool is it that
we have built this community for our
school you know one day it's going to be
awesome when somebody else builds this
for the world because something like
this needs to exist for the world but it
didn't even occur to me that you know my
friends and I might be able to play a
role in doing that right because we were
college students right I mean we didn't
have any you know Engineers to to work
with or servers or resources or anything
like that and you know there were these
huge companies that deliver products for
hundreds of millions of people right
there's you I always assumed that it was
going to be like Microsoft or Google or
uh someone would build this for the
world and what basically just happened
is um at each step along the way we just
kind of kept doing the next thing and uh
growing from there and you know there
there were teams inside these other
companies that that thought social media
was important and were working on it but
you know there were all these different
memes and and narratives uh in the world
you know people would say oh well you
know this is just a fad people are going
to use it but then they're going to stop
so um you know so a lot of the teams we
were working on didn't take it that
seriously or you know the the higher ups
and those companies didn't care so they
didn't get resources and we just kept
going and going and then people would
say all right well all right fine so
maybe people are using it but it's never
going to make any money right I mean
social media doesn't make any money and
we just kind of kept going and uh going
and then pretty soon we had a service
that was uh bigger than any of these
other ones and that kind of is how we
are here where we are um there's no
magic a lot of times I think people just
get afraid because you know often your
dream is it's it seems like it's so um
so far off but but if you just kind of
focus on building stuff that you think
is good and uh and and you keep on going
at each step along the way and don't let
people deter you from that and you just
really care about what you're doing and
kind of don't give up at each step along
the way then um you know I think that's
how you uh that's how you build
something good I built the first version
of Facebook because it's something that
my friends and I wanted to use uh at
Harvard a directory and a way to connect
with the other people around us and I I
didn't think at all that it was going to
be a company I I remember very
specifically the night that that we
launched um the first version I I went
out to uh to get pizza with um a couple
of my friends who um who who now work
here and you know and I remember really
clearly we were talking about how one
day we thought that someone was going to
build a community like this for the
world uh and that that would be some
company but like it clearly wasn't going
to be us I mean it's it just it wasn't
even it didn't even occur yeah no I mean
it wasn't even an option that we
consider that it might be us I mean we
we just weren't focused on building a
company back then we were just building
something that that that we thought
would be useful at our school with
Facebook there was just such you know
people loved it right and and had such
an intensity of using it I think within
a couple of weeks uh 2third of students
at Harvard were using it and all these
other students at MIT and other local
universities were writing in asking us
if we could open up uh Facebook at their
school so we kind of just followed that
right and you know again we didn't I I
didn't set out and you know my roommates
didn't set out to to build a service
that we were going to turn into a
company but we just kind of followed
what people wanted and that led us to
expand it to all these other schools and
um and eventually Beyond School and to
you know at some point uh once we'd
hired a bunch of people we decided to
turn it into a company and and and um
and go for this mission of connecting
the world but that's not where we
started you know I always think that you
should start with the problem that
you're trying to solve in the world and
not start with um deciding that you want
to build a company right me the best
companies that that get built are are
things that are trying to drive some
kind of social change even if it's just
local in one place uh you know more than
starting out because you want to make a
a bunch of money or or have a lot of
people working for you or or build some
company in some way so you know I always
think that this is kind of a perverse
thing about Silicon Valley in a way
which is that you know people decide
often that they want to start a company
before they even decide what they want
to do and that just feels really
backwards to me and you know for anyone
who's had the experience of actually
building a company you know that you go
through some really hard things along
the way and I think part of what gets
you through that is believing in what
you're doing and knowing that what
you're doing is is really delivering a
lot of value for people um and and
that's I think how the best companies
end up getting made I think the media
there's a little bit of this cultural
bias towards thinking that you know one
person does this right I mean people say
that you know I built Facebook or Steve
Jobs built apple or whatever but you
know that's really not true right I mean
it's we're we're people we we helped uh
but there were thousands and thousands
of other people involved in building
these things and
the reality is is that as strong as any
one individual is no one person can deal
with all the challenges that are going
to get thrown at them in in anything
that you do and one of the ways that I
think we maintain resilience is by
having um co-founders and partners who
complement our strengths and uh fortify
our weaknesses and can kind of encourage
us and give us a push to to keep going
when things are tough and there's
actually a lot of data on this that
suggests that companies that get started
with more co-founders are more likely to
be successful and it isn't quite clear
um exactly from that data why that's the
case although it is very clear in terms
of the outcome for the startups that it
is the case um but I would guess that
the reason why that's the case is
because of this resilience point where
people who start something by themselves
I I just think like there's no way that
anyone person can overcome all of the
different things that you need to do to
to build a startup or take on any kind
of other project in the world but if you
have two or three or four partners then
I don't know I mean maybe over time one
of them doesn't like it and and drops
out but you still have enough strength
on the team to power through all the
challenges that you have and that's kind
of how you go and you know at Facebook
today one of the things that I always
find a little bit funny is again that so
much attention is placed on on me as the
person running the company whereas I
think you know people like Cheryl um who
really you know as my partner running
the whole business or you know folks
like Chris Cox who run a huge amount of
our product or Mike shreer who's our
chief technology officer and and kind of
make sure that a ton of uh what we're
doing works or J Peri who you know runs
all of our Global infrastructure and in
all the data centers around the world we
we couldn't make Facebook work without
those people right and and there were
really hard days where where I'm not
sure what to do next and and and they
keep me going Steve Jobs cared a little
bit too much about how perfect the edges
of some polygon were right um what is it
that you care too much
about connecting
everyone no seriously if you think about
I mean it's like this aesthetic sense of
the world that I have is that you can
communities of people can Channel their
energy to do great things and having
connections between people is the
infrastructure for the world to do that
and you know that's why at each step
along the way when there was always all
this uncertainty about you know whether
it would be profitable or whether it
would make sense or be good or whatever
to do these things um we always were
doing it because we just cared more and
I mean to this day I mean you could you
could say that that was a startup thing
but it isn't because I now we're we're
here and we connect more than a billion
people but I mean we're pouring tons of
money and resources into connecting
people who can't even afford internet
access right so I mean that's like
there's no way that that's going to be
profitable in the near term or medium
term but we're doing it because we think
it's the right thing to do and over the
long term I do think that there's
something there and it's going to be
fundamentally important for the world
and maybe we'll get rewarded maybe not
but we just really care recently you
shared in a press conference that one of
Facebook's focuses for the next decade
is that it is more important to be
understood than be
liked will you just share what you meant
by
that yeah I
mean look
it's let's be real here I'm not I'm not
like communicating is not my best thing
right um you know I I came out here been
planning for this I'm excited about it
and then I messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds so so I
mean look when when I got started with
Facebook I was
19 and um and I there were so many parts
about building a company that I didn't
know right I didn't I didn't know
anything about hiring or managing or
building a company and I certainly
didn't really know that much about you
know how to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world I mean I'm I'm an
engineer by training right I I I I love
coding I like Building Products that's
that's kind of the background um and uh
you know my experience you know kind of
growing up and running the company is
went out talked about what we did say
some stupid things get called out for it
and get like kind of go into a into a
shell right and and uh end up being
really cautious about how we communicate
so you know that it kind of it worked
out okay for a while for the company
because we we built products that a lot
of people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well I
think in spite of the fact that we were
communicating quite poorly about what we
were doing but broadly speaking for a
long time uh the basic approach was okay
let's try to not
like do anything that's going to be too
offensive right and and we'll kind of
explain what we're doing and Broad
strokes and talk about the mission of
what we're doing which is something that
I really believe in helping to build
community and and and bring people
closer together but you I think we we
just shied away for a long time talking
about some of the things that um some of
the principles that we believe in that
that um that are increasingly
controversial in the world and I I just
think that we for one don't have that
luxury anymore um for two uh I I think
that that kind of LED for a while to a
sentiment towards the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if if if you're not kind of out
there standing for things that uh that
people care about then you know it's not
possible for people to feel that
strongly about what you're doing but so
now you know I I've just I've tried to
change our approach more recently you
know I went out and I in Georgetown last
year I gave this speech around our
principles around free expression and
you know that's just one of the areas
that I really feel like is under attack
right now there's probably stuff you can
say about something Insight that you had
early on and you thought to yourself aha
nobody else knows this except us but we
have this we have this great this great
trick do you remember any of them well
Peter teal was really focused on network
effects and he had this model that I
think is right for making decisions that
as the complexity of the company grows
every day you're going to be faced with
a hundred things that you could
potentially go do and your job is to
pick the one thing that actually matters
because out of those 100 it's really
only actually going to be one or two
things that actually matter and that was
pretty informative to me at the time
because I had
intuitively like I had a lot of um some
self-direction intuitively but as soon
as I started getting all these people
around me um who all had reasonable
perspectives on things was very hard for
me to balance that and um Peter was
always very useful for for that um we
were he was good at saying here's the
one thing that matters like focus on the
one thing that matters well partially
that and partially just the metal lesson
of figure out the one thing that matters
and do that but remember what the one
thing that mattered like if someone con
everyone as quickly as possible because
I mean Network effects were a massively
important part of this one of the the
stories when you say connecting everyone
as quickly as possible you don't mean
specifically getting more signups you
mean getting people to friend one
another faster yeah how did you do that
um well we built a lot of tools to
enable people to do what they already
wanted to where you can't like push
uphill on this stuff right it's it's um
we were solving a problem that people
had and we just needed to remove as much
friction as possible if you want to
learn computer science just you know K
wrote the book buy it okay uh you know
read it and do the problems for if you
really think you know this thing if you
want to learn physics Fineman wrote the
book uh just read the damn book it's all
there so the when we put stuff
online it we don't have anything in
online physics that's any better than
fineman's book honest honestly now it's
a little easier to learn uh you know the
guy makes jokes every 20 minutes or at
least tries to uh and he does more demos
and things so learning is a weird social
phenomena and so you know our foundation
our big problem is that the group that
does the worst with online learning are
low-income students because their notion
of why am I learning their sense of
self-confidence the ability to figure
out oh I just got stuck because you know
two minuses cancel out and I I never saw
that notation before they just hit dead
ends all the time that if you're sitting
in your dorm at Stanford you know
somebody walks down and uh helps you get
through it I think success is always a
bit dangerous uh you know and you can
think that whatever your success was was
because you know you were
magically uh uh gifted in understanding
things whereas of course any success
particularly a gigantic success is a
huge number of factors including hard
work and understanding but timing you
know other people who came to work with
you other people who might have done the
same thing who somehow messed up uh in
doing it and so often you'll you'll have
too much confidence about what you
understand uh you know in science uh as
fan said the easiest person to fool is
yourself uh and so you have to force
yourself to go through
uh you know again and again and think
through is this the right thing to be
doing you know will this work am I doing
it because it would be exciting if it
succeeded am I really looking at these
factors in fact in polio several times
we had to say to ourselves was it time
to give up uh or really did we think
there was a prospect of uh being able to
move forward when your mother first said
I'd like you to come and have dinner uh
with me and Warren Buffet will be here
you should meet him you didn't seem that
interested why was that well I thought
of somebody who bought and sold
Securities which is a very zero suome
thing that's not curing disease or a
cool piece of software and the idea of
you know kind of looking at volume
curves and it doesn't invent anything
and so I thought my way of looking at
the world what I wanted to figure out
and do and what he looked at that there
wouldn't be much intersection and that's
why it was so shocking when I met him he
was the first person to really asked me
about software and software pricing and
why wasn't IBM with all of their
strength able to overwhelm Microsoft and
what what was going to happen in terms
of how software would change the world
and you know he let me ask him about
okay well why do you invest in certain
industries and why are some banks more
profit than others and he he was clearly
a broad systems thinker and so it
started a conversation that has been fun
and enriching and uh you know an
incredible friendship that was
completely unexpected the biggest impact
a company can have is staying within its
area of expertise uh so you know to make
sure that the education systems around
the world that they get good software
and we have a donation program where
we've done called it's called partners
and learning we have deals with 132
countries how we grant them software and
fun teacher training in each of those
countries so Microsoft's main thing will
be about that Library access that school
access the free software the training
you know the job skills and the partners
that are in that uh country uh not not
not so much health care and whereas the
big drug companies we need to get them
into the healthc care issues and the
banks we need to get into micro finance
and the food companies we need to get
into micronutrients and buying the
output of the farmers in these poor
countries so that the their economies
get going so I think everybody's got a
big role to play but it's it's going to
be fairly centered on the thing that
that the employees know and uh drives
their their specific contribution I
remember one great fear I had uh when we
did Microsoft research was
that the if we weren't careful it'd be a
block to our view of what was going on
in the academic community that is we
would hire somebody who had an approach
and that Academia as a whole would have
like 20 approach is you know number of
which would likely be better than some
internal approach and so I wanted
somebody who was open-minded enough to
say no the you know this group here uh
is doing it the right way uh and I was
worried would that fluidity exist a lot
of these programs like having students
come here like The Faculty Summit have
contributed to the idea that okay we're
part of a broader community community we
publish great things you know people
come and go a lot so I feel super good
about that in terms of work uh you know
I would say the most of the opportunity
to make computers improve work is in
front of us in set of behind us only at
kind of a very mechanical level of uh
it's better than white out uh you know
are we like oh wow this thing helps me
get my work done uh for extremely
structured tasks like creating financial
statements you know where the
application logic is very opaque and
you're just LED through it or for very
horizontal things where you really
understand what you're up to and the
Machine doesn't see oh that email is
part of personnel review that emails
part of planning the uh the Salesforce
meeting so we have kind of the the
low-level horizontal which in this ways
amazing and then we have this very
structured applications world the idea
of of matching what you and your head
have is the atttention of the overall
activity in the sem mantics around it uh
and therefore sort of maximally helping
you with those things I think now uh
that a lot of base level things are are
done very well including Gathering the
data and learning from it that we should
be able to have what the machine thinks
you're up to and what you think you're
up to match each other uh and improve
the productivity qual quality quite
dramatically you were just a college
drop out you were very youngl looking
did you get taken seriously by
businessmen who are much older for some
people that youth uh and geekiness uh
was like Hey should we trust them you
know that's so weird we've never seen
something like that before so yes we had
to fight for acceptance I couldn't rent
cars uh so I had to take cabs around CU
I was too young and you know probably
some people were a little tough but then
as as we got a little bit of su success
people were fascinated by this deep
belief we had in in software certainly
during the time I was at Harvard I
wasn't sure what I was going to do uh
the idea that software was this field
that uh was the opportunity was
unbelievable that became more obvious
during the three-year period I was here
uh but my dad had been a lawyer I
thought of mathematics you know like
doing well in the putham that was the
coolest thing
uh and the computer software I didn't
think those people were as smart as the
math people so I it's like well am I
going to go into the easy field uh or
this really hard field but uh anyway
math uh was fantastic when I finally
picked and decided to go go to Microsoft
then I got into a period from age uh
19 uh to about 40 where I wasn't able to
look at the latest on you know how
tornadoes work or how mitochondria work
I was pretty
monomaniacal and when I was able to ask
Steve this is the year 2000 Steve
Balmer uh he he mistakenly graduated uh
but then he started at St
uh well I was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine but then he
started at Stamford business school and
he was in his first year on oh this is
perfect I'll get him to drop out of
Stanford Business School uh so in a
certain sense he is a Dropout uh uh and
he was very key to the sucess of
Microsoft I mean uh he knew a lot of
things but during that period I didn't
get to do much at Harvard you know I
took all these courses because it was
just so amazing that people were
interested and talking about them and uh
I I have to say I never went to a
lecture during reading period or any
anything because the courses that I was
actually signed up for I finally started
to work on those uh so I was in Hell the
minute would open to the minute would
close during reading period trying to
catch up on on that other set of courses
so people say I'm a Dropout which is
literally
true but because I like college courses
the online college courses there's a
company called The Learning Company that
I buy uh tons and tons of their stuff
and I do you know at least four or five
courses a year in a sense I like uh
going to college more than anyone uh so
know I've sort of made sure my job
certainly post
Microsoft uh that I get to spend my time
meeting with Scientists uh learning new
things you know seeing what the hard
problems are and some cases giving money
to people to take on uh those very very
hard problems the key thing was that
Paul Allan and I had loved working on
software since we were lucky enough to
be exposed literally I was 13 and 8th
grade when this time sharing terminal
came in and we just did it day and night
and you know got better and we could see
that the magic of software combined with
this miracle of the micro processor
subject to Mo's law exponential
Improvement that that was a magic
combination and we we'd look around and
say hey how come everybody's not saying
this is amazing I mean we're going to
Dethrone IBM and uh you know why doesn't
digital equipment get it why is the guy
who runs it this is a company that's
long gone uh but dominated many
computers at the time why isn't that guy
up there saying it's it's wrong we know
it's right and so the key event for us
was it was a very cold Boston winter and
a kit computer came out on uh this
popular Electronics magazine and we said
oh damn this is happening without us I
mean here we are uh doing nothing and so
we called the company up and said you
know hey we're ready
uh and then we called them back we
actually did the work and then we called
them back and said how do you make the
stuff go in and out of the computer the
io and they said well that's interesting
nobody else has ever asked that you must
really be doing something so that was
anyway our very first customer and so we
grabbed on to it to be the very first
and we were the first to say there
should be a software industry and and
come and do it in a sense it was one of
the lower risk things I've ever done in
my life because you know I could have
always gone back uh you know well my
parents my dad didn't say hey if you go
away for a few years I'll stop paying
for your education they were nice and
said okay go you know learn your lesson
down there in the desert and uh then you
get back to the serious stuff and you
know we're still we're still waiting so
do you have any regrets in your life you
seem to have a life that most people
would love to live you got a happy
family great marriage Foundation
business success is there anything can
you make us feel good by saying you've
done something that didn't work out or
just make us cuz all of us feel bad cuz
we look at you and we can't do what
you've done so tell us something that's
bad that you've done or you feel
inadequate about something there must be
something I am super lucky uh you know
they Mar
Melinda uh they experience at Microsoft
uh that although it has its ups and
downs was uh phenomenal uh the work of
the
foundation and no regrets about anything
I wouldn't try and go back and change
anything I I mean for example the
antitrust lawsuit against Microsoft you
know was bad for the company it created
a lot of distraction we would have done
a lot of things including the mobile
operating system better if it hadn't
been for that but in a way it was a
lesson for me uh and you know so it and
it probably accelerated my retirement uh
by five or six years which overall for
me probably was a a good thing uh you
know I don't think it was a principled
set of activities but that's another
story the idea that computers were going
to be a change agent you know I was
lucky enough to meet Paul Allen and
early on we brainstormed about this I
did the chip and the chip changed the
rules I mean most things don't get a
million times better not you know engine
efficiency or uh you know most things
have uh theoretical minimums
computation is something that uh we're
not even close to the theoretical
minimum and yet we've improved so much
so seeing that that was going to come
and weirdly that most people didn't see
that was going to come so you know even
people at IBM were still thinking in
terms of big computers you know now all
the the uh software and service driven
companies are worth even more than IBM
when I was growing up IBM was the
monolith and it was always okay are we
going to beat him are we going to join
them those bastards actually they were
very nice people but but we always
thought of them uh and they they sort of
stood for these big computers that only
big companies and governments could get
the benefit for so actually we played
off of that to have this power to the
people personal Computing type thing of
course now we're a big company uh and
somebody can play off of us the idea
that a young person can start a company
here is a a super nice thing because
although people at first are skeptical
as soon as they realize their normal
model of what I knew and what I could do
that I didn't that normal model then
they assumed I knew way more than I did
and I could solve all sorts of problems
I had no clue uh you know how to solve
but you know it was nice uh that people
were kind of a Gog that we had built
this company and done these things from
a young age so I think the culture of
America that you know almost the
American dream type success story uh
worked out computers when I was young
were super expensive and my friend Paul
Allen and I actually snuck into places
at the University of Washington where
they had computers that weren't being
used at night and so we were fascinated
by what the computer could do but very
few people were getting exposure we had
to go out of our way and we were lucky
that we did it all and so then when the
idea of moving the computer onto a chip
that Intel would make and that would
make the computer literally millions of
times cheaper than the ones we were
using so both more powerful andov
ailable to people on a personal level
then the idea of okay it would be very
different the software you needed the
way the industry would work we were
super lucky
to uh be there when that was happening
so what did your family think did they
say there's something wrong with this
young man he wants to just do computers
they knew I was obsessed with computers
that I would skip Athletics that I'd go
in overnight that I'd you know leave the
house sometimes when they prer I would
go work at night on these things and so
I was kind of considered a little
strange and the big moment was when I
said instead of going to part of my
senior year that I wanted to go work uh
for company writing software so they
were great about allowing that to be my
hobby if you want to have impact uh
usually delegation's important um
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things that's
phenomenal so when Microsoft first got
started I wrote most of the code and
everybody else's code I read and kind of
rewrote uh and that got us up to 10
people and then I had to say to myself
okay we're going to ship code that I
didn't edit uh and that was hard for me
uh but you know I kind of got over that
then I still said okay I'm going to
interview everyone and I'm at least look
at samples of their code well that got
us up to about 40 people and that was at
a point where I had sold way more
software than we could write uh because
everybody was so impressed and I thought
well I need to keep enough collect
enough money to you know keep hiring all
these people but uh the demand was so
high that you know we were actually
falling behind that's when I hired Steve
and Steve figured out a uh how to
control what promises I made to people
uh and B how to hire lots of people and
good really good people and create
organizations and teams so I delegated
to Steve that and he was constantly
saying to me okay we're going to hire
programmers that you've never met and
I'd say no we're not and then he he
would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't going to work uh you
know so uh then I said okay then I would
you know know all the managers of the
people and so over time uh and of course
you know I could say the quality per
person was falling monotonically
uh uh according to me uh but you know
large problems uh if you want to you
know write the most popular office
productivity software that one person
absolutely can't do that you can write
pretty code so everyone has to decide
what scale of organization they want to
work in eventually you know my role was
very much as a leader and a reviewer of
managers but the top people and I hired
some super experienced people uh I would
make sure they were pursuing a common
vision and they were well coordinated
but in terms of a lot of management
stuff they were way better than I was
now I had to have the framework to know
what mix of skills that we needed and
you know when they were working well
enough together but a lot of uh you know
my value added was
picking say to do Graphics user
interface or to do an integrated office
office uh type thing or to go Global and
not use agents to have Microsoft be
present all over the world and so yeah
picking what you're good at and how you
find the other people uh to fill in
those things that's super important and
most Founders don't aren't able to scale
that up and kind of give up the Hands-On
things that they used to get a lot of uh
pleasure and comfort from I think you
know you can over worship and
mythologize the idea of working
extremely hard for my particular
makeup I mean it really is true that I
didn't believe in weekends I didn't
believe in vacations I mean you know I
knew everybody's license plate so I
could tell you over the last month when
their car come and gone from the the
parking lot so I don't recommend it a I
don't think most people would enjoy it
uh once I got into my 30s I could hardly
even imagine how I had done that uh
because by then some natural behavior
kicked in and I loved weekends and uh
you know my girlfriend liked vacations
and that turned out to be kind of a neat
thing uh now I take lots of vacations my
20-year-old self is so disgusted with my
uh current uh uh self you know I I was
sure I would never do anything but
riding coach you know now I have a plane
so it's it's very much counter
Revelations have taken place at at high
speed
but yes it is nice if during those first
several
years if you have a team that's chosen
to be pretty maniacal about the company
and how far that goes you you know
should have a mutual understanding so
you're not uh one person expecting one
thing another person expecting another
thing and you'll have individuals who
who have you know health or relatives or
things that are distracted but yes I
have a fairly hardcore view that there
should be a very
large uh sacrifice made during those
those early years I think the the
quality that uh has helped me in lots of
things uh is a kind of measurement
scientific framework where I go in and
say did anybody handle this well what
what are the very best practices uh do
we have numbers on that and let's get
everybody measuring what they're doing
and so they can strive to match what
that the best achievement is uh for us
often that's something like getting the
vaccines out to all the children some
very poor countries uh do that extremely
well because they get down to that local
level and measure the activity they make
sure the inventory is there they make
sure the workers are showing up so for
me I always uh look at how can we do
better better measurement and use that
to drive uh the very best practices most
people over the last 200 years or so
whoever they the wealthiest person in
the world was didn't usually work that
hard when they got to be 60 or so they
kind of took life easy you seem to be
working pretty hard what motivates you
to still work so hard well I love my
work the work of the foundation is super
interesting I get to meet with the
scientists I get to go out in the field
I do think your habits are sort of set
in your 20s and
30s and by my standards of the 20s you
know I didn't believe in weekends back
then uh not to mention Vacations so I'm
you know fairly lazy compared to myself
in my 20s where I was a true uh fanatic
uh you know all I believed in was
working on software night and day and
and for my 20s that was perfect I didn't
have a wife or family uh at all and my
rule was very hand Hands-On
rule
how do you think about the metaverse
what is it and what are the steps to
make it real yeah so the way I think
about this I mean I think you're right I
think the metaverse and web 3 are
related Concepts but are also distinct
uh the metaverse I I think of as an
immersive internet sort of the the next
chapter of the internet after the mobile
internet the successor if you will um
there's always a platform that comes
next and I think that the metaverse is
is going to be that and I think that the
defining characteristic of it is that
you'll be able to feel um like you're
present with other people in it and if
you're designing social interactions and
and kind of uh platforms for people to
to interact with each other which is
basically what I spend my life doing um
the ability to help people feel present
with another person and all that goes
into that right it's you know feeling
like you're there feeling like like you
can see people's Expressions clearly
like you can make eye contact like you
can um kind of physically interact um
you know hear where they're coming from
spatial audio you know be able to
express yourself in three dimensions all
all these things that go into a feeling
of presence I just think is going to
deliver way better social experiences
and a feeling of togetherness than any
other technology that we've had before
and we try to kind of simulate that on
phones and and other screens that we
have you know we're we're doing this you
know and right now and I can I can see
on a screen it's it's nice functionally
I can I can see her face so so that's
nice but I don't think you know neither
of us is under any illusion that we're
we're um you know we don't feel like
we're together um so I just think in the
future whether you're in virtual reality
or um augmented reality and you know
maybe we do a version of this
conversation in the future where you
know I'm a hologram on the couch next to
you um and and you can see that through
your glasses um or or any of the other
platforms that are getting built I think
that that's just that's going to be just
to unlock a lot of new social
experiences and then on top of that
you're going to be able to do all kinds
of new forms of entertainment um new
types of hanging out um more physical
types of computing like things around
Fitness that don't really make sense on
mobile phones um or or computers today
and and I think it's going to transform
work too right because they'll just be
able to walk anywhere you want and snap
your fingers and have your perfect
workstation up and then if you want to
collaborate with someone they'll kind of
show up as an avatar or a hologram next
year and you have that too so um so that
set of things is um is how I think about
the metaverse and um and I think you're
you're right that we're certainly
investing more than anyone else is in
this um there's a lot of science that
needs to still get solved a lot of this
isn't just you know engineering
questions around all right let's go
build stuff over the next few years
there're actually unsolved questions
that need to get worked through and um
we have kind of hypotheses on how that
might work but for a lot of the hard
questions we have you know five six
seven teams um you know trying to take
different bets on it and we'll see see
what works um so that's an important
part of it and I I do think that that
will end up being an important
contribution to the whole field and I'm
excited that we're doing that I love it
when the things we buy go down I mean
that I mean I just I get you foric you
know the stocks are down today and I'm
buying more of something I was buying
yesterday I'm buying it cheaper now when
you go to the grocery store and you buy
something cheaper than you bought it the
day before you think that's terrific but
people with their stocks they they think
that the stock knows more than they do
so that they when the stock goes down
they say the stock is telling them
something you know and and what it's
telling me is I can get more for my
money but but they uh they take it as
kind of a referendum on themselves you
know and it's me versus the stock if it
ever gets back to what I paid I'm going
to sell it stock doesn't care what you
paid you have to remember the stock
doesn't even care that you own it you
are nothing to the stock that's that
stock is everything to you you know and
you remember you paid
$10.3 and therefore the stock should get
to 1013 before you sell it you know the
stock has no feelings about you
you I hate to disillusion on this but it
it just doesn't care and so the only
question with every stock every day and
you don't do it this frequently is can I
get more for my money someplace else
you've got a chance to be in thousands
and thousands of great businesses and
their prices change all the time so
their relative valuations change and you
can make the exchange at very low cost
these days commissions or nothing and so
you can always shift from one business
to another you have a huge advantage
over Andrew Carnegie you know when he
was in the steel business he was in the
steel business or rocker was in the oil
business he could not shift over
immediately to retailing or something
like that you you can rearrange your
business Empire which you own through
that little portfolio that you have you
can rearrange that you know at a
moment's notice with practically no cost
it's a huge advantage
which people turn into a disadvantage uh
there is nothing about the price action
of the stock that tells you whether you
should keep owning what tells you
whether you should keep owning it is
what you expect the company to do in the
future versus the price at which it's
selling now compared to the other
opportunities of businesses that you
think you know equally well and make
that same comparison and that's all
there is to owning stocks you really
have to believe the internet's going to
be mainstream a lot of people are going
to get out there and use it and that
they're going to be willing to pay for
some content is that the operating idea
that you have well each of these
businesses uh is an entrepreneurial
business uh the overreaching theme is
that yes I believe in the internet I
believe it'll get increasingly popular
and we're doing some neat new things to
take advantage of that is you've got a
lot of cash on hand yes right all right
it puts you in an enviable position you
can experiment with a lot of entrepr
urial ideas and see what sticks and what
flies well we're we're in business to
make money and but the other thing is
providing such a cash flow for you well
it all belongs to the shareholders we're
not diletant we are business people and
it is true that if you find an idea that
requires three or four years of
improvement and patience I'm really
sticking with it uh that we're very good
at that take Windows which we BET our
company on everybody doubted that would
succeed IBM did not support us in that
uh it took longer than we expected uh
over 4 years before finally graphical
interface got popular and now people
take it for granted it's part of every
personal computer and you just you just
expect it to be there that was one of
the grand successes of the company in
the same way we're betting on the
internet that our tools there will be
popular and that a few of these content
plays that we've decided to get involved
in that the scale and and the users will
make those into great businesses for
Elon musk's 10 rules for Success check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there Elon Musk a man who
turns science fiction into reality a
Pioneer a disruptor a Visionary The Man
Behind SpaceX Tesla and neurolink from
electric cars Define the fossil fuel
industry